Oh my God. Oh, the house lights. Take your time with the house lights. Oh, wait. Yeah. Oh, wait. Take your time with the house lights. I don't know what you're supposed to do.
我的天。哦，阶梯亮灯。对阶梯亮灯别着急。哦，等等。对，哦，等等。对阶梯亮灯别着急。我不知道你该做什么。
I don't, uh, this isn't, can, well somebody, yeah, give it to me. How about you just, you wait, you just had a red ball. I need to be slapped to be woken up. Okay. I'm gonna slap you, the, as far as I want you, I want, I'm gonna slap you, as hard as I want you to slap me.
我不知道，呃，这不是，能，好吧，有人，对，把它给我。要不你，等一下，你刚拿了个红球。我得挨巴掌才能清醒过来。好吧。我要扇你，那个，只要我想，我想，我要扇你，像我希望你扇我那么用力。
I'm just, I'm shunned. You just slap me. Okay. I want, I'm gonna slap you as hard as I want you to slap me. I'm shunned. You just slap me. I just slap much. Okay. Harder than that. Okay. I think we're on right now. Oh. We should, yeah.
我只是，我被冷落了。你刚才扇了我。好吧。我想，我要像我希望你扇我那么用力地扇你。我被冷落了。你刚刚扇了我。我只是扇了一下。好吧。比那更用力。好吧。我想我们现在正在播。哦。我们应该，对。
Okay, shut up. So, no, we gotta do the thing. No flash photography. Don't use your fucking cell phone. Ow! There we go. That was a block. No flash photography.
好吧，闭嘴。所以，不，我们得做正事。不要用闪光灯拍照。别用你们他妈的手机。哎哟！这就对了。那算是一个阻拦。不要用闪光灯拍照。
Don't use your fucking cell phone. Don't record. Have a good time Say hi your neighbor Oh My god Oh my god I'm Addison you nice people Very nice
别用你们他妈的手机。不要录像。玩得开心，向你的邻居打个招呼，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，我是艾迪逊，你们这些好人，非常好
Yeah He's already this The sweatshirt. Oh, sit down. Sit down, sit down. Sit down, sit down. It's a perchera set. Beautiful, beautiful theater. Yeah.
对，他已经这样了。这件卫衣。哦，坐下。坐下，坐下。坐下，坐下。这是一套表演场地。美丽，美丽的剧院。对。
A beautiful town. We, we, we finally made it to Madison Wisconsin. Good thing. Okay. I got it. I got to say a little bit, you know, as you guys know, you're a big part of the podcast and coming here today kind of feels a little bit like a home game. Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
美丽的小镇。我们，我们，我们终于来到威斯康星州麦迪逊了。太好了。好吧。我明白了。我得说一点，你知道的，正如你们所知，你们是播客的重要一部分，今天来到这里感觉有点像打主场。对，对，对，对。
You know, like a badger game or like a badger game. I was cheap. That know? We're good. Like a badger game. We're like a badger game. That was cheap. That was a cheap applause line. That was very cheap. Sorry about that. Or like, some people were like, I don't give a shit about the fuck you're bad. Yeah.
你知道的，就像一场獾队比赛或者像一场獾队比赛。太便宜了。你知道吗？我们很好。就像一场獾队比赛。我们就像一场獾队比赛。那太廉价了。那是个廉价的喝彩梗。那非常廉价。不好意思啊。或者像，有些人会觉得，我他妈才不在乎你是什么獾。对。
Or like a bowling game. I bowl a lot. Maybe I bowl. Anyway. Anyway. So, we want to say thank you to you guys for wanting to see us. We wanted to see you. So this is awesome that this worked out.
或者像打保龄球。我经常打保龄球。也许我会打保龄球。不管怎样。不管怎样。所以，我们要对你们想来看我们表示感谢。我们也想见你们。所以这能成行真是太棒了。
And a shout out to the Edgewater Hotel who housed us for four hours today. Yeah. It's right on a frozen lake and us soft little L.A. freaks were like, well, that lakes frozen. I see people walk on it. Should we go walk on it? So we walked on it.
还要感谢今天让我们住了四个小时的边缘水酒店。对。它就坐落在结冰的湖面上，而我们这群娇气的洛杉矶怪胎当时就在想，哇，那个湖结冰了。我看到有人在上面走。我们应该去上面走走吗？于是我们在上面走了。
And we walked on it. You can walk on a frozen lake. Yeah. That's amazing. It was very cold right there at the Edgewater. Well, they look as a Canadian, I on it. You can walk on a frozen lake. Yeah. It was very cold, right there at the edgewater. Well, they look as a Canadian, I get it. Okay. Not to pull rank too much, but...
我们在上面走了。你可以在结冰的湖面上走。对。太神奇了。边缘水酒店那里非常冷。好吧，作为一个加拿大人，我懂。你可以走在结冰的湖面上。对。边缘水酒店那里非常冷。好吧，作为一个加拿大人，我懂。好吧。为了不显得太摆谱……
Did you ever play hockey on a frozen lake? Sure. Really? Yeah, of course. How many times? Again, I'm Canadian. No, but I mean, not every Canadian plays hockey or on a frozen lake. Yeah, no, I have done it.
你有没有在结冰的湖面上打过冰球？当然。真的吗？对，当然。多少次？再说一次，我是加拿大人。不，我的意思是，并不是每个加拿大人都打冰球或在结冰的湖面上玩。对，不，我做过。
But it's a fair question. And we did get out there. You wanted to go. We were up at the Edgewater Hotel. I don't know. And they were super nice. We were there for like two hours. But we, Jason saw the icing, saw people walking across.
但这是一个合理的问题。我们确实去那儿了。你想去。我们当时住在边缘水酒店。我不知道。他们人超级好。我们在那儿呆了大约两个小时。但是我们，杰森看到了结冰，看到了人们走过去。
He's like, we got a kid out there. And it shone back. And Sean was like, what are they doing? And neither of them had ever been out on a frozen lake before, with you guys Know is just what you do. Yeah Hey, let's sit down. Yeah, let's sit down. We're gonna get down. Yeah, so Let's see
他就像是，我们得去外面。肖恩也回来了。肖恩就问，他们在干嘛？他们俩以前从来没有去过结冰的湖面上，跟你们一样，都知道这就是你要做的。对，嘿，我们坐下吧。对，我们坐下吧。我们要坐下来。对，所以，我们来看看
So we have different I've been sitting in that seat for a couple of days. Yeah, it's nice to be over here I want to see these people too. All right so couple of days. Yeah, it's nice to be over here. I want to see these people too. All right. So I, you know, I like to start out like with a personal story that happens, you know, on the material. No, I don't have material. Dig in everyone, someone's prepared. I do have a cocktail. No, I, you know, on the tour, by the way, we are living together on the tour. We're living in one suite, like, yeah. Turns out he's messy. Yeah, not true.
所以我们有不同的我已经在这个座位上坐了好几天了。对，很高兴来到这边我也想见见这些人。好吧，所以好几天了。对，很高兴来到这边。我也想见见这些人。好吧。所以，你知道，我喜欢从一个发生在身边的个人故事开始，你知道，关于材料的。不，我没有材料。大家切入正题吧，有人准备好了。我确实有一杯鸡尾酒。不，我，你知道的，在巡演中，顺便说一句，我们在巡演中住在一起。我们住在一个套房里，就像，对。事实证明他很邋遢。对，不对。
He's not. You don't sleep well. I don't sleep well. You like the snacks? I mean, I like, I mean, what? Yeah, you like the snacks. I do like the snacks. Oh, it is.
他不是。你睡得不好。我睡不好。你喜欢零食？我的意思是，我喜欢，我的意思是，什么？对，你喜欢零食。我确实喜欢零食。哦，是的。
No, I do get a lot of shit from you about, you know, eating sprouts and no gluten. I mean, now that you see, I do get a lot of shit from you about, you know, eating sprouts and no gluten. I mean, now that you see, I eat terribly. You can see. Well, here's what it is, and we don't want to bore you too much, but we're going to do it anyway. We, what we realize is, as you know, Sean, and you guys know, Jason gives me a lot of shit
不，你确实经常拿我开涮，关于，你知道的，吃芽菜和无麸质食物。我的意思是，既然你看到了，我确实经常被你开涮，关于，你知道的，吃芽菜和无麸质食物。我的意思是，既然你看到了，我吃得很糟糕。你可以看出来。好吧，事情是这样的，我们不想太烦你们，但我们还是要这么做。我们，我们意识到的是，正如你们所知，肖恩，你们也知道，杰森经常拿我开涮
about eating and what I eat, blah, blah, blah. Have you noticed all the time that he gives me shit and then he ends up eating all the time? Yeah, all the time. Yeah, all the time. But it was classic today, right before we switched a little bit and Jason ordered a burger and will order to salad, which is so rare.
关于吃什么和我不吃什么，等等等等。你有没有注意到他总是拿我开涮，然后他自己却一直在吃？对，一直在吃。对，一直在吃。但今天真经典，对吧，就在我们稍微转换了一下之前，杰森点了一个汉堡，威尔点了一份沙拉，这太罕见了。
And then the salad came. But the salad came and it was the fried chicken salad. Fried chicken salad. But anyway, so, but wait, what? Still a salad. Low-hanging fruit is still fruit. But wait, and then Jason did offer me at a burger, and he offered me his, you did at one point,
然后沙拉上来了。但沙拉上来了，那是炸鸡沙拉。炸鸡沙拉。不管怎样，所以，但是等等，什么？依然是沙拉。低垂的果实依然是果实。但是等等，然后杰森确实主动分了汉堡给我，他把他的，你确实在某个时刻，
legitimately say, I'll give you the rest of my waffle fries for your salad. Yeah. It is true, I did offer you my gluten bun too. Oh, yeah. Oh, God. All right, so, but on the tour, these guys one day I came back into the room and these guys have had had massages.
理直气壮地说，我用我的华夫饼薯条换你的沙拉。对。千真万确，我还把我的无麸质面包也分给你了。哦，对了。哦，天哪。好吧，所以，但是在巡演中，有一天我回到房间，这两个家伙刚做过按摩。
And so I was like, oh, it's bummed in. And so Jason was like, oh well, you can still get one willy-nilly trying to get me figured out how to get one. I'm like, you know what, forget it. So yesterday in Chicago, I got a missus. I got a facial because I couldn't get a missus. God, we sound so strong.
所以我当时想，哦，太遗憾了。所以杰森就说，哦，好吧，你还是可以随便找一个，试着帮我搞定一个。我说，你知道吗，算了吧。所以昨天在芝加哥，我做了一个按摩。我做了一个面部护理，因为我没做成按摩。天哪，我们听起来太强壮了。
So strong. It's a word. Yeah, wow. By the way, we're having hours of record. Wait. You were the record for the record. I did not get him inside. Yes, you did.
太强壮了。这是一个词。对，哇。顺便说一句，我们在记录时间。等等。你是为记录创造了纪录。我没有被按摩。是的，你按了。
No way, didn't. Well, you'll let us out. I'll let you out. I'll let you out. I'll let you out. Yeah, whatever you did. But so I got this little thing today. And this Russian woman is like,
不可能，没有。好吧，你让我们出去。我放你出去。我放你出去。我放你出去。对，无论你做了什么。但今天我得到了这个小东西。然后这个俄罗斯女人就像是，
like, misaging my shoulders after she put, I don't know, some fucking stuff on my face. And she's, misad, she goes, I don't know where I can't do a Russian accent, but she's like, oh, you strong muscles, you work out. And I was like, ugh, God, I don't know what this is. It's already making me feel uncomfortable. But I love funny misad stories.
就像是，在我脸上不知道抹了什么他妈的东西之后，开始按摩我的肩膀。然后她按摩着，她说，我不知道我能不能模仿俄罗斯口音，但她是那种，哦，你肌肉很强壮，你锻炼。当时我就想，呃，天哪，我不知道这是什么。这已经让我感到不舒服了。但我喜欢有趣的按摩故事。
I have two really quick. One, the first time I was... Wait, when you were king yourself up for your own... Absolutely. Absolutely, oh, this one I'm king. Actually. This gets better. It gets better.
我有两个非常快的。一个，我第一次……等等，当你在为自己的……加油时。绝对是，绝对是，这个我要加油。实际上。这个越来越好。越来越好。
Why the night gets better. One is, one time this friend of mine offered, he's like, this guy just sports machizers. I'm like, all right, I'll try that. So I'm lying on the thing. I never had a sports machiner for him. And I have the little thing over me. And I'm totally naked underneath.
为什么夜晚会变得更好。一个是，有一次我一个朋友提议，他说，这有个家伙提供运动按摩。我说，好吧，我试试。于是我躺在那个东西上。我从来没有做过运动按摩。我身上盖着小毛巾。我里面完全是光着身子的。
And this guy starts pulling one leg over this way, and then one leg over this way, and my penis and balls are over here. Whoa. And my penis and balls over here. And none of it was relaxing or comfortable or anything. And I thought the sheet was supposed to be the invisible barrier between us,
然后这家伙开始把一条腿拉向这边，然后把另一条腿拉向那边，而我的阴茎和蛋蛋就在这里。哇。而我的阴茎和蛋蛋在这里。没有一点是放松的、舒适的或什么的。我以为床单应该是我俩之间无形的屏障，
but it was everywhere. But anyway, my philosophy, my philosophy, my philosophy for massages is this. If they say, hey, do you want a male or a female, I always ask for a female. And this is why. If it being gay, or a new slash. So if it's a straight-eye gay massage and something
但它到处都是。但无论如何，我的哲学，我的哲学，我对按摩的哲学是这样的。如果他们问，嘿，你要男技师还是女技师，我总是要求女技师。原因如下。如果是同性恋，或者新消息。所以如果是直男去按摩，有什么
happens, I don't want them to freak out. If it's a gay guy and something happens, I don't want them to be like, hey, and if it's a woman, I'm good to go. Oh. Go ahead, go ahead, cancel yourself. We're going to do it in Madison, Wisconsin. What a night. What a night. Have you ever had uncomfortable situation on the massage table? No, I don't think so.
事情发生，我不想让他们惊慌失措。如果是个同性恋男按摩师，有什么事情发生，我不想让他们觉得，嘿，如果是女的，我就万事大吉了。哦。继续，继续，取消你自己的资格。我们要去威斯康星州麦迪逊这样做。多美妙的夜晚。多美妙的夜晚。你在按摩台上遇到过不舒服的情况吗？不，我不这么认为。
Well, you know what prompted me to tell the story. I have a story. You would remember. A nice clean know would have done it. No, I had a masseuse one time get up on the table and she got up on me a little bit. Yeah, and it was, you know. Were you in the country?
好吧，你知道是什么促使我讲这个故事的。我有个故事。你肯定记得。一个体面的回答本来就行了。不，我有一次按摩师爬上了按摩台，她稍微压到了我身上。对，那是，你知道的。你在国内吗？
In this country? Yeah. What, do you consider Latvia part of this country? No. So she, her technique was to get up on you? She got up, yes. She got up on my back, which I think is, yeah, irregular, now that I think about it.
在这个国家？对。怎么，你把拉脱维亚当成这个国家的一部分吗？不。所以她，她的技巧就是爬到你身上？她爬上来了，是的。她爬上了我的背，我觉得，是的，现在想想这挺不寻常的。
She did, did she have a saddle with her? No. Uh, I, it was, when she took her clothes off, that's, that was a signal. That's, no. But that was it. that's the only time you had an uncomfortable massage. I don't think so.
她确实，她带了马鞍吗？没有。呃，我，当她把衣服脱掉时，那就是，那是信号。那是，没有。但就是这样。那是你唯一一次遇到不舒服的按摩吗？我不这么认为。
I mean, no. There was, there was, um, a friend? No, no. Things, things change a little bit, but they don't go, things didn't get to where they get to. Your honor, permission to treat the witnesses hostile. Wait a minute.
我是说，没有。曾有过，曾有过，嗯，一个朋友？不，不。事情，事情有点变了，但它们没有发展到它们该有的地步。法官大人，请求将证人视为敌意证人。等一下。
What about that story you told me today, but that actually did happen to a friend of yours, which is all my friend. Yeah, my friend of mine's wife goes to this pretty reputable massage place in Los Angeles. And we can't tell this story yet. No, but they don't want to hear about this kind of stuff. That's like, that's... She...
你今天跟我讲的那个故事呢，其实是发生在你一个朋友身上的，也就是我所有的朋友。对，我一个朋友的妻子去洛杉矶一家相当有声望的按摩店。我们还不能讲这个故事。不，但他们不想听这种东西。那就像是，那是……她……
Well, tell shit stories on the podcast. No, I'll tell a cleaner massage story that I was actually in. I actually said, oh, you're going to get both now. No, so she was in this nice massage place and she's enjoying a nice massage and she's face down and she's got herself a a male Russian massage therapist. Why are they always Russian? Because they're strong, man. And she receives a thumb.
好吧，在播客里讲烂俗的故事。不，我会讲一个更干净的按摩故事，我实际上亲历了。我实际上说，哦，你现在两样都要经历了。不，所以她在那家不错的按摩店里，正在享受舒适的按摩，她是趴着的，她给自己找了一个男俄罗斯按摩师。为什么总是俄罗斯人？因为他们强壮，老兄。然后她收到了一根大拇指。
Wow. Wow. Everything stops. He stops because he's wondering if he's going to receive a solid green instead of the flashing green. She stops because she's wondering if it's a mistake. Then she turns her, what's going on?
哇。哇。一切都停止了。他停了下来，因为他在想自己是会收到绿灯常亮还是闪烁的绿灯。她停了下来，因为她在想这是不是个失误。然后她转过身去，怎么回事？
He stops the thumb and then finishes him, says she's so freaked out, she goes to pay at the end. She tips him. She, because she's so freaked out, she goes to pay at the end, she tips him. She, because she's not sure what she should be. He already tipped her. Hell. She goes, she goes home, she tells her husband, right? Because she's freaked out, right?
他停下了大拇指，然后结束了，她说她吓坏了，最后去付账。她给了小费。她，因为她吓坏了，最后去付账，她给了小费。她，因为她不确定自己该怎么做。他已经给过她小费了。见鬼。她去，她回家了，她把这事告诉了她丈夫，对吧？因为她吓坏了，对吧？
So he's freaked out. He picks up the phone. He calls the massage place and he explains the situation. He says, you know, my wife is in there. She's got a massage from a massage therapist there and she was dumb. And and and the person says, you know, I'm sorry, so that's impossible. Who is a massage therapist? And he says, I don't, honey, who is a massage therapist? And he says, I don't, honey, who is a massage? It was Yuri. And the guy says it was Yuri. And the person of the desk says, well, that's on because Yuri's our most requested massage therapist. And they both paused.
所以他也吓坏了。他拿起电话。他打电话给按摩店，解释了情况。他说，你知道，我妻子在那里。她在那里接受了一个按摩师的按摩，然后她被碰了。然后，那个人说，你知道，我很抱歉，这不可能。谁是按摩师？他说，我不知道，亲爱的，谁是按摩师？他说，我不知道，亲爱的，谁是按摩？是尤里。那个人说那是尤里。前台的人说，嗯，那是不可能的，因为尤里是我们最受欢迎的按摩师。他们两个人都停顿了一下。
And the person of the massage was like, oh, got it. We will speak to Yuri. So that was that story. So, and let me get digits after the show of where that place is. So, you know, we're here because one of the main reasons we're here is because my sister lives in Wisconsin. And, yeah, yeah. And, as you know, Tracy.
按摩店的人说，哦，明白了。我们会和尤里谈谈的。那就是那个故事。所以，演出结束后，让我打听一下那个地方在哪里。所以，你知道，我们来到这里，我们来到这里的主要原因之一是因为我姐姐住在威斯康星州。然后，对，对。而且，正如你们所知，特雷西。
And, you know, just one quick, Tracy story, she came to pick me up at college after my fourth year, and she picked me up in some pickup truck or something, and we got high before we got into the truck, and we got stoned. What? Drugs.
而且，你知道，关于特雷西的一个快速故事，她在我大四后去大学接我，她用一辆皮卡车什么的来接我，我们在上车前抽了大麻，我们嗨了。什么？毒品。
That's a good one. And so we got stoned. We smoked pop before we got it. And we loaded the trucking with just like, really nearly, like just a clothes and like my dress, my dress or whatever. And so we've driving, driving, and driving. And we're driving up 55 from ISU, Illinois State University. And I'm driving up, and we're both like listening to Madonna.
这是一个好故事。所以我们嗨了。我们在上车前抽了草。我们把行李胡乱塞进卡车里，就像，随心所欲地，就像衣服和我的裙子，我的裙子什么的。然后我们一直在开车，开车，开车。我们沿着55号公路从伊利诺伊州立大学（ISU）往上开。我开着车，我们俩都在听麦当娜的歌。
And we're both like in our own world. Like we're actually Madonna. I'm like, just like prayer. That voice would take us there. And like we're in the video or something. In our own world, we're not really talking. Obviously, I don't open my eyes and in the rearview mirror, I just see some pants.
我们俩都沉浸在自己的世界里。就像我们就是麦当娜。我就像是，伴随着祈祷。那个声音会带我们去那里。就像我们在录像带里或者别的什么。在我们的世界里，我们并没有怎么说话。显然，我没有睁开眼睛，在后视镜里，我只看到一条裤子。
And then a shirt. And then she's like driving. And she's like, holy shit. Some more pants and some socks, and like a suit, and then like part, and then we're like, maybe we should pull over. We pulled over, and I'm talking like two miles of clothes behind us, right?
然后是一件衬衫。然后她正在开车。然后她说，操。更多的裤子和袜子，还有一套西装，然后像一部分，然后我们觉得，也许我们应该把车停下来。我们靠边停车，我说的是我们身后两英里的衣服，对吧？
And we just, what do we do? Should we go back and get in? No, we didn't give it, we just drove the fuck home. You were so, yeah. Because you did not zip your bags, uh, adequately. I was 18, or I'm sorry, I was 20, I don't know what. Are you, are you high now? Yeah, I love it.
然后我们，我们该怎么办？我们应该回去拿吗？不，我们没有拿，我们他妈的直接开车回家了。你当时太，对。因为你没有把包拉好，呃，充分地。我当时18岁，或者抱歉，我20岁，我不知道是多少。你，你现在嗨了吗？对，我喜欢。
But you know, why finish any of these stories? When I, when I can have Tracy tell them herself, she read. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Oh my Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, my God. Tracy. Oh, my God.
但是你知道，为什么要讲完这些故事呢？当我，当我能让特雷西自己讲的时候，她读了。对。对，对。对。哦，我的，对。对。对。哦，天哪。特雷西。哦，天哪。
All right. Madison's own Tracy. OK. She doesn't look like she needs anything explain to her. All right, so I have these questions that I literally wrote about an hour ago. Don't let her peak. What was one of the best memories you have of me?
好吧。麦当娜本地人特雷西。好的。她看起来不需要任何人向她解释什么。好吧，所以我这些问题是我大约一个小时前写的。别让她偷看。你对我最好的记忆是什么？
What they look alike, I think, cute. I think, or of our family or anything. Well, growing up, we had just us five kids. Yeah, chaos. Just us five kids. That's why you need to explain things to me. Yeah. Oh, do you see? do you help the explanations on the podcast? You think they help you? Yes, we say Tracy. Can you explain? Yes? I do yes. Yeah, do you guys have any questions for my sister?
他们看起来很像，我觉得很可爱。我想，或者关于我们的家庭什么的。嗯，从小到大，我们只有我们五个孩子。对，一片混乱。只有我们五个孩子。这就是为什么你需要向我解释事情。哦，你看？你在播客上需要解释的帮助吗？你觉得它们对你有帮助吗？是的，我们说特雷西。你能解释一下吗？是的？我确实需要的。是的，你们对我姐姐有什么问题吗？
How about this how about used to be a police officer? I'm obsessed with crazy police stories. You have a crazy one We used to be a police officer. Yeah, hang on a second. We didn't know that. So what I worked for is in the audience. Oh, yeah, Phil. Hi, Phil. Yeah, so I was a cop. We lived in Glen Island, and all that were the worst thing that would happen, and something was like.
这个怎么样，曾经是个警察怎么样？我对疯狂的警察故事着迷。你有一个疯狂的故事吗？你曾经是个警察。等一下。我们不知道。所以我工作的地方在观众席。哦，对，菲尔。嗨，菲尔。对，所以我曾是一名警察。我们住在格伦岛，所有最糟糕的事情都会发生，有些事情就像是。
But you always say that. You weren't there. No, like, OK. I was a cop for 15 years, and in Glen Island, where we grew up. And you, did you ever have a case? was cafer of 15 years and in Glen Island where we grew up. Did you ever have a case? Did you ever work on a case of a weed-smoking couple who lost a bunch of clothes on the highway?
但你总是这么说。你当时又不在场。不，就像，好吧。我当了15年警察，在长大的格伦岛。而你，你有没有接过一个案子？当了15年警察，在长大的格伦岛。你有没有接过一个案子？你有没有处理过一对在高速公路上弄丢了一堆衣服的抽大麻的夫妇的案子？
Did you guys ever solve that case? What was the most dangerous thing you're ever involved with as a cop? I mean, there was know burglaries and domestic, quite domestic. Did you see any dead bodies? Yeah, I don't. You did? No way. I think you told me one.
你们破过那个案子吗？你当警察时经历过最危险的事情是什么？我是说，有些盗窃案和家庭纠纷，相当多家庭纠纷。你见过尸体吗？对，我不知道。你见过？绝不可能。我觉得你跟我说过一个。
And that became normal to you? Yeah, that doesn't matter. Okay, great. Really? Really? What was the oldest dead, like how long had it been dead? Oh. Not the oldest person.
那对你来说变得很正常了？对，那没关系。好吧，太棒了。真的吗？真的吗？最老的死者是谁，就是死了有多久？哦。不是年纪最老的人。
No, there was an old elderly lady that the male kept piling up, and then you go in to a neighbor called. So it was like a week? A maggots. Oh, no. What about, did you ever see anybody get dead? Oh, like a...
不，有一位老太太，信件一直在堆积，然后邻居报了警。所以大约是一个星期？蛆。哦，不。还有，你有没有见过任何人死掉？哦，就像一个……
Is that the way you say it? I'm not dying. I even died, he made longer. You can't. No, Gavin Fondre. Did you ever see anybody like die in front of you? No, no. God, that must be scary.
你是这么说的吗？我没有死。我甚至死过，他活得更久。你不能。不，加文·冯德雷。你有没有见过什么人当着你的面死掉？不，不。天哪，那一定很吓人。
And what is your last name? I'm kidding. Yeah. So, were you a motorcycle cop And what is your last name? I'm kidding. Yeah. So. Were you a motorcycle cop or did you drive a car? I drove a car, and then I became a detective. And then, yeah. Well, she did.
你叫什么姓？开玩笑的。对。所以，你是骑摩托车的警察，你叫什么姓？开玩笑的。对。所以。你是骑摩托车的警察还是开车？我开车，后来我成了一名侦探。然后，对。好吧，她是的。
She could have been a motorcycle cop. Don't look at me. We didn't have motorcycle cops. We don't have motorcycle cops? No. Oh, because of weather, right? What? We got motorcycle cops, all the LAs lousy with motorcycle cops.
她也可以当个摩托车警察。别看着我。我们没有摩托车警察。我们没有摩托车警察？没有。哦，因为天气，对吧？什么？我们有摩托车警察，洛杉矶到处都是摩托车警察。
Now you can see in person what we're dealing with is it's absurd. But no, I think that that's a pretty good question. If you are in a place that has a lot of winter, you can't have a motorcycle cop because you got snow and ice. Good for you, dude. I figured. You see the way I have a process that I figure stuff out. What is it like?
现在你可以亲眼看到我们在对付什么，这太荒谬了。不过不，我觉得这是一个相当不错的问题。如果你在一个有很多冬天的，你不能有一个摩托车警察，因为你有雪和冰。真为你骄傲，老兄。我想也是。你看我弄清楚事情是有流程的。这是怎样的？
Do people bug you because you're referenced on the podcast? Do people stop you? They don't know who you are. What is it like? I get kind of some emails like that. I don't really figure out it's you? I don't know. Really? Yeah, I don't know because I have a different last name.
因为你在播客里被提及，人们会烦你吗？人们会拦住你吗？他们不知道你是谁。这是怎样的？我确实会收到一些那样的电子邮件。我真的没意识到那是你？我不知道。真的吗？对，我不知道，因为我有一个不同的姓氏。
Right. And I live in Monaco. Ha, ha, ha. Right. I got to change that now. Yeah. Yeah, I don't know how they figured out, but sometimes some people do.
对。我住在摩纳哥。哈哈，对。我得把这个改了。对。对，我不知道他们是怎么发现的，但有时有些人会。
It's fine. I don't know. Oh, fucking weird is it. It is weird. Right. And all these people know who you are because we talk about you all the time, good shot.
没关系。我不知道。哦，真他妈奇怪。这很奇怪。对。所有这些人，因为我们一直在谈论你，都知道你是谁，干得好。
Right, it's weird. Yeah, so you know, here's the thing. I am a single mom, and I'm at home, and I literally, it makes my Monday. I think it makes everybody's Monday morning. So look forward to that. I am not kidding. Yeah, so I really appreciate you guys.
对，这很奇怪。对，所以你知道，事情是这样的。我是一个单身妈妈，我在家里，我真的，它成就了我的周一。我认为它成就了每个人的周一早晨。所以期待那个。我不是在开玩笑。对，所以我真的很感激你们。
That's what I'm hoping. That's a wonderful place to end. No, I want one question. I have one question I have here. Wait, she's not going anywhere. We gotta go. We gotta go. I just want to hear.
这就是我所希望的。这是一个完美的结束地方。不，我想要一个问题。我这里有一个问题。等等，她哪儿也不去。我们得走了。我们得走了。我只是想听听。
I know, but hang on, hang on. I just want to ask you this. Your brother, Sean. That's me. Yeah, just zip it for one second. Is our good friend. We love him very, very much. And he's an incredibly talented guy.
我知道，但是等等，等等。我只想问你这个。你的弟弟，肖恩。那就是我。对，闭嘴一秒钟。是我们很好的朋友。我们非常非常爱他。他是一个非常有才华的人。
How, yeah, how? Very nice. When Sean moved to California and then he had all this incredible success, did you say yes, I knew it, and did you feel an incredible sense of pride for all the amazing things that your brother's done well or or? Was it wait till they figure out the mistake they've made
怎么，对，怎么？非常好。当肖恩搬到加州并取得所有这些难以置信的成功时，你有没有说，是的，我早就知道，你是否为你弟弟所做的一切惊人的事情感到一种难以置信的自豪感，还是？还是在等他们发现自己犯的错误？
I know I think he's he's a great brother. I mean he's a very We're very close. We've always been the closest I think that nice We were the two youngest and so we kind of stuck together Oh, I have a I made him do We were the two youngest, and so we kind of stuck together. Oh, hi. How about this? I made him do like, the ton lessons cheerleading. Yeah, he's good.
我知道，我觉得他是个好弟弟。我是说，他非常，我们非常亲密。我们一直是最亲近的，我觉得太好了我们是最小的两个，所以我们有点抱团哦，我有一个我让他做我们是最小的两个，所以我们有点抱团。哦，嗨。这个怎么样？我让他做拉拉队跳舞课程。对，他很擅长。
I mean, it was bad. She did. You want to do a cheer together again? No, I do not. I do not want to. Go please to a cheer. No, please. No. Oh my gosh.
我是说，那很糟糕。她确实。你想再一起跳一个拉拉队舞吗？不，我不想。我才不要。请跳个拉拉队舞吧。不，求你了。不。哦，天哪。
It is second. No, no, no, no, no. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh. Wait a second. What, I didn't hear you guys said you used to be on cheer squad together? Well, no, she's just taking cheer. I would would be like a cheerleader and I make him do the practice
这几秒钟。不，不，不，不，不。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。等一下。什么，我没听你们说你们以前一起在拉拉队呆过？嗯，没有，她只是在练拉拉队。我会扮演拉拉队队员，我让她做练习
with me in the time for it. Right now, right now. I know what I'll do. I'll do it. Right now. But really quick. OK, I'm going to do it. Here we go.
跟我一起，按时完成。就现在，就现在。我知道我要做什么。我会做的。就现在。但非常快。好吧，我要做了。我们开始吧。
Get up there. I'm not doing it. I am not doing it. OK, ready? This is what she taught me. Ready? 5, 6, 7, 8. We've got power wild cat power
上去吧。我才不干。我才不干。好吧，准备好了吗？这是她教我的。准备好了吗？5，6，7，8。我们有力量，野猫力量
P. O W. E. R. We've got we've got power Thank you for coming out. Thank you, Tracy. Here we go. Thank you. That was awesome. That was awesome. We'll be right back. Smart List is sponsored by ADT.
P. O. W. E. R. 我们有，我们有力量。谢谢你们的光临。谢谢你，特雷西。我们这就回来。Smart List 由 ADT 赞助。
Now ADT professionally installs Google Nest products, so your home is safe and smart. You can check in on your home and manage your security system from virtually anywhere. With Nest Cam's and the Nest Doorbell, you can even get intelligent alerts so you receive notifications on what matters most. Google Nest Cam's can tell the difference
现在，ADT 专业安装谷歌 Nest 产品，让您的家既安全又智能。您可以几乎从任何地方查看您的家并管理您的安全系统。通过 Nest 摄像机和 Nest 门铃，您甚至可以获得智能警报，以便收到关于最重要事情的通知。谷歌 Nest 摄像机可以分辨
between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest doorbell, even a package. And with Nest aware, as part of your monthly ADT service, you get 30 days of event video history and even smarter notifications like when a familiar or unfamiliar face is seen. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name in home security adds the intelligence of Google, you got a
人、动物、车辆的区别，或者通过 Nest 门铃，甚至可以分辨包裹。作为每月 ADT 服务的一部分，借助 Nest Aware，您可以获得 30 天的事件视频历史记录，甚至更智能的通知，例如何时看到熟悉或不熟悉的面孔。另外，当每一秒都很重要时，您可以信任 ADT 的 24/7 专业监控。只需轻轻一按，即可查看报警事件的视频并验证或取消警报。当家庭安全中最受信赖的名字加入谷歌的智能技术时，您就拥有了一个
home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP. Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. This episode of Smart List is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. And listen, I've said it before and I'm going to say it again. Thank you Richard Erlich for the quote. This body is no fluke and it's brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn, okay? A deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil, and salt, every bite of the perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you and me wanting more.
无忧无虑的家。今天就访问 ADT.com 或致电 1-800-ADT-ASAP。谷歌、Nest 摄像机、Nest 门铃和 Nest Aware 是谷歌有限责任公司的商标。本期 Smart List 部分内容由 Skinny Pop 爆米花赞助。听着，我以前说过，我还要再说一遍。感谢理查德·埃里希提供这句话。这身材绝非偶然，它部分由 Skinny Pop 爆米花为您呈现，好吗？爆米花、油和盐的美味简单组合，每一口完美爆裂的原味爆米花都让你我都想要更多。
Skinny Pop is light, it's tasty, and it's perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, staving off boredom or unwinding after a long day. And in addition to the original popcorn gang, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors, ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle. I'll say it again, this body is no fluke,
Skinny Pop 很轻盈，很美味，非常适合任何场合，无论您是在路上、摆脱无聊还是在漫长的一天后放松身心。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop 还提供各种美味的口味，从白切达干酪到甜咸味。我再重申一遍，这身材绝非偶然，
but I do recognize you can't see me, so I'm gonna help you with a little description here. The silhouette that I get going when all I eat is skinny pop and water, it's something to really behold. It's tough in the winds. Fortunately, we don't have a lot of strong wind here in Los Angeles, so I'm good there.
但我知道你们看不见我，所以我来帮你们做点描述。当我只吃 Skinny Pop 和水时，我的这种体型，真的是值得一看。在风中很艰难。幸运的是，我们在洛杉矶没有太大的强风，所以我很好。
But boy, I venture out of the country or up onto a mountain top. I got to do more, skinny pop. Lots of skinny pop just to wait me down a bit. Shop skinny pop now on Amazon. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot.
但是天哪，我冒险出国的或者去山顶。我得吃更多 Skinny Pop。大量的 Skinny Pop 只是为了把我压重一点。现在就在亚马逊上购买 Skinny Pop。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。
It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot.
这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。这是一个好镜头。
It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. It's a good shot. books across every genre. You'll find guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities, renowned experts, and exciting new voices in audio. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. The audible app makes it easy to listen anytime anywhere, while traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. So I've been checking out Atomic Habits by James Clear. I love his last name. It's so apropos. It's a great, great audiobook. It'll teach you exactly how to form good habits, break bad ones, and master the tiny behaviors
涵盖各个流派的书籍。您会找到引导式健康计划、戏剧表演、喜剧以及来自顶级名人、知名专家和音频领域激动人心的新声音的独家 Audible 原创内容。作为 Audible 会员，您可以从整个目录中每月选择一本书保留，包括最新的畅销书和新发布。Audible 应用程序使您可以随时随地轻松收听，无论是旅行、锻炼、散步还是做家务，由您决定。所以我一直在看詹姆斯·克利尔的《原子习惯》。我喜欢他的姓氏。太贴切了。这是一本非常非常棒的有声书。它会准确地教你如何养成好习惯，打破坏习惯，并掌握微小的行为
that lead to amazing, amazing results. I really, really highly recommend it. You know, we always joke about on the podcast how we don't read, but listening to an audiobook seems to be more time efficient for us, and I really, really enjoy actually listening to books. It's fantastic. I'm reading again with my ears. New members can try Audible Free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible Free for All right, back to the show.
从而带来惊人的、惊人的结果。我真的非常非常推荐它。你知道，我们总是在播客里开玩笑说我们不读书，但听有声书对我们来说似乎更省时，而且我真的非常喜欢听书。太棒了。我正用耳朵重新阅读。新会员可以免费试用 Audible 30 天。访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。那是 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500 以免费试用 Audible。好吧，回到节目中。
Let's move on, shall we? Where are we going? We're going to go in and all trapped Jason. OK, here we go. You guys are in for a special treat. This is exciting. You know how you want, I had to write it down. Me and Jason write our intros down.
我们继续吧，好吗？我们要去哪里？我们要进去把杰森全困住。好的，我们开始吧。你们要大饱眼福了。这太令人兴奋了。你知道你们有时怎么想的，我不得不把它写下来。我和杰森把我们的开场白写下来了。
You know how you wonder sometimes how certain people in our business become successful. And then they sustain that success, right? Sure you need talent and brains and ability to capture an audience. But I found the secret ingredient to becoming a superstar is being a nice person. Huh, right?
你知道有时你为什么会好奇我们行业的某些人是如何成功的。然后他们如何维持这种成功，对吧？当然，你需要才华、头脑和吸引观众的能力。但我发现成为巨星的秘诀是做一个好人。哈，对吧？
This person is one of those people. He's one of the nicest kind of people I've ever had the pleasure of being friends with. He is the first person to introduce me to a segue, the scooter, not how to connect thoughts. He's played an attorney, a pickpocket, a talking shrimp, and a spy for the FBI. He also happened to appear with me
这个人就是这样的人。他是我有幸结交的朋友中最善良的人之一。他是第一个向我介绍赛格威（一种滑板车，而不是如何连接思想）的人。他扮演过律师、扒手、会说话的虾和 FBI 间谍。他也碰巧和我一起出现在
on one of the funniest episodes of Will & Grace. Unlike how he's treated by Jimmy Kimmel, we have plenty of time for him tonight. It's Matt Damon! What? Whoa! Whoa! Whoa!
《威尔与格蕾丝》最有趣的剧集之一中。与吉米·坎摩尔对待他的方式不同，我们今晚有的是时间留给他。有请马特·达蒙！什么？哇！哇！哇！
Whoa! Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
哇。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
对。对。对. 对。对。对。对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah's what I know. That's why I said. I know you're probably wondering who canceled and thank you for replacing at the last minute. You're very welcome.
对。对。对。这就是我所知道的。这就是我说的。我知道你可能在想是谁取消了，谢谢你最后一分钟来顶替。不用谢。
Yeah. So, we used to... You know what's so funny? We used to remember this. I bring this up every time I see you. We used to play softball about 75 years ago with the Olsen twins. Yes.
对。所以，我们曾经……你知道什么最有趣吗？我们曾经记得这个。每次见到你我都会提起这个。大约 75 年前，我们和奥尔森双胞胎一起打过垒球。是的。
Yeah. Yeah, it was me. And when they were little kids, that's right. Yeah. And what was the league? What was the league? No, it was me. And when they were little kids, that's right. And what was the league? What was the league? No, it was like, meet at this fucking at a park in Santa Monica. Just meet at this park. The Olsen twins will be there.
对，是我。当他们还是小孩子的时候，没错。对。那是什么联赛？什么联赛？不，是我。当他们还是小孩子的时候，没错。那是什么联赛？什么联赛？不，就像，在圣莫尼卡的公园里见。就在这个公园见。奥尔森双胞胎也会去。
You can play softball with them? Yeah. Is that like a flyer on a telephone pole? No, our friend Steve Shenbaum organized these softball things. And I remember like remember like playing with you and we were hanging out and you go, because it was right at the peak of William Grayson, you go, how can you go out anywhere?
你可以和他们一起打垒球？对。那是电线杆上的传单吗？不，我们的朋友史蒂夫·申鲍姆组织了这些垒球活动。我记得，就像和你一起玩，我们在闲逛，你说，因为那是《威尔与格蕾丝》的巅峰时期，你说，你怎么能去任何地方？
I'm like, how can you go out anywhere? And you're like, yeah, but you're Sean Hayes. I'm like, you're fucking mad, Damon. It was crazy. You can cruise around with a fair amount of anonymity, yes? Oh, yeah, yeah. Yeah. But you live in New York, yeah? Yeah, most of the time.
我说，你怎么能去任何地方？然后你说，对，但你是肖恩·海斯。我说，你他妈可是马特·达蒙。这太疯狂了。你可以带着相当程度的匿名性四处走动，对吗？哦，对，对。对。但你住在纽约，对吧？对，大部分时间。
And now, are you like, you can just go to the store and do whatever, right? So, yeah. We were talking about this yet. You go to the store a lot? I do, actually. Well, in New York, yeah. And when I lived in LA, I probably never went to the store,
现在，你是那种，你可以直接去商店做任何事情的人，对吧？所以，对。我们之前还在讨论这个。你经常去商店吗？我确实去。嗯，在纽约，对。当我住在洛杉矶时，我可能从来没去过商店，
but in New York, kind of, nobody cares. Nobody gives a shit, right? Nobody cares, nobody cares. Nobody cares. But there are some people, we're talking about this the other day. There are some people, would you not agree? There's some people who sort of carry themselves like a celebrity, and then other people do not,
但在纽约，某种程度上，没人会在意。没人他妈在乎，对吧？没人会在意，没人会在意。没人会在意。但有些人，我们前几天还在讨论这个。有些人，你不同意吗？有些人表现得像个名人，而其他人则不会，
I don't know what it is, whether what they wear or how they act or what, I don't know, but you've always been to me a really famous actor as opposed to some, you know, big flashy celebrity, but you have all the fame of a celebrity, but you're people think of you as a... Right, you're not a TikToker, right? You know, like... Well, I'm trying.
我不知道是什么原因，无论是他们穿的衣服还是他们的行为方式，还是什么，我不知道，但对我来说，你一直是一个真正伟大的演员，而不是某种盛气凌人的大明星，但你拥有名人的所有名气，而人们认为你是一个……对，你不是 TikTok 博主，对吧？你知道，就像……嗯，我在努力。
Are you trying? Are you trying? Are you working on it? I mean, if you want my kids to... I'm not. No, are you out of your mind? No. Shunny is, I am. Yeah, I do things like that stupid thing.
你在努力吗？你在努力吗？你在为此努力吗？我的意思是，如果你想让我的孩子们……我没有。不，你疯了吗？没有。夏尼是，我是。对，我会做那种愚蠢的事情。
Right, do you like it, Chair? No, then I have to get on TikTok and follow you. But my kids won't let me get on TikTok, you're right. Because they're like, Dad, you're lame. You can't get on TikTok, really. Yeah, yeah. We were going through that about the dad lame thing, and Jason was worried I accused him of looking like cool dad tonight.
对，你喜欢椅子吗？不，然后我不得不上 TikTok 并关注你。但我的孩子们不让我上 TikTok，你是对的。因为他们就像，爸爸，你太逊了。你不能上 TikTok，真的。对，对。我们一直在讨论爸爸很逊这件事，杰森还担心我指责他今晚看起来像个酷爸爸。
Yeah, I got a terrible outfit on today. I don't know. You look great. No, what'd you call me? Rock and roll dad. Rock and roll. With this ridiculous hair, I need to get kind of like Chrissy Hine. I have that going too, because I have to go. This thing I have to do in LA tomorrow for the next movie, it's like one of the hair and makeup tests.
对，我今天穿了一件糟糕的衣服。我不知道。你看起来很棒。不，你叫我什么？摇滚老爸。摇滚。顶着这荒谬的头发，我需要弄成克里西·海因那样的。我也有那种发型，因为我必须去。我明天在洛杉矶为下一部电影做的事情，就像是发型和化妆测试之一。
You have an excuse. They tell you not to cut your hair as shave for a month. Right, you don't have to wear this ridiculous denim outfit. I don't. I'm at the end of the tour, I'm down to all loose ends, you know? Short ends. I want to go, because I like that topic about you being an actor, not just like a personality, because it's true. And you went to Harvard, but you only I want to go, because I like that topic about you being an actor, not just like a personality,
你有个借口。他们告诉你一个月内不要剪头发也不要刮胡子。对，你不用穿这身荒谬的牛仔装。我不用。巡演快结束了，我只剩下一些零碎的事情了，你知道吗？短尾。我想继续，因为我喜欢关于你是一名演员而不仅仅是个性的话题，因为这是真的。你上了哈佛，但你只……我想继续，因为我喜欢关于你是一名演员而不仅仅是个性的话题，
because it's true. And you went to Harvard, but you only went for one year and you go for four years? Or what? I went for five years. But I got credit for three of them. No, what would happen would, I'd get to, like, wherever I was in a semester, if I got a job, I'd take the acting job and then you know and then go away and then come back and take a leave of absence and go away and come back and
因为这是真的。你上了哈佛，但你只读了一年，你是去读了四年吗？还是什么？我去了五年。但我拿到了三年的学分。不，事情是这样的，我会去到，不管我在哪个学期，如果我得到了一份工作，我就会接下这份表演工作，然后你知道的，然后离开，然后再回来，请假离开，然后再回来，
there was one semester I mean I was three weeks away and I said can I just finish I'm just about done I just have to take my finals and they said you can do it if you take your finals at the exact moment they're offered in Cambridge and I'm like, I can't shut a movie down for three hours, four different times. I'm number nine on the call sheet. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Yeah, I wasn't, I just like, right, I'm just. Was it hard?
有一个学期，我的意思是，离结束还有三周，我说，我能直接读完吗？我快完成了，我只需要参加期末考试。他们说，如果你能在剑桥提供考试的准确时刻参加期末考试，你就可以完成。我说，我不能为了三个小时关掉一部电影，分四次进行。我在演员表上排名第九。对，完全正确。完全正确。对，我不是，我只是，对，我只是。很难吗？
Like, it. What? This is the school? Just chumarum. So, but I just, from what I've been told, was Harvard hard. But this is why I ask because I have heard that people say you'd be surprised,
就像，它。什么？这是学校？只是胡说八道。所以，但根据我所听到的，哈佛很难。但我之所以这么问，是因为我听说有人说你会大吃一惊，
college in general is not as difficult as a high level high school program. Like if you take AAP classes or what, I don't have a high school diploma. Just bear with me. That, like the general ed in college is not as difficult as it can be in high school because it's voluntary school and they're not really grinding you.
总的来说，大学并没有高级别的中学课程那么难。比如如果你选了AP课程之类的，我其实没有高中毕业文凭。大家多担待。那个，大学里的通识教育其实没有高中时那么难，因为那是自愿选择的学校，他们不会真的拼命折磨你。
You're trying to discipline yourself. You're disciplining yourself. No, no, no. It's so fun watching his brain work and how he thinks about stuff. It's amazing. What was it difficult? I mean, it depends.
你在努力克制自己。你在训练自己的纪律性。不，不，不。看他的大脑运作以及他是如何思考问题的，真的太有趣了。太神奇了。它真的很难吗？我是说，这得看情况。
For me, it was always if I liked the class, it wasn't difficult. Because it's like kind of like, you know, if you have the job you love, you never really are working. People go, well, you work so it's such long hours. And you go, no, I mean, I'm. But aren't those first two years you
对我来说，总是如果我喜欢这个课，它就不难。因为这有点像，你知道的，如果你做着自己热爱的工作，你就永远不会觉得是在工作。人们会说，噢，你工作了这么久，时间太长了。而你会说，不，我是说，我是。但难道头两年你
have to take general ed? You have to take the there's a second two years where you get to say well now I want to be uh you know uh this person they had they had core requirements right so you had to no matter what you were studying they wanted to make sure you took a lot of different classes across the syllabus so you guys you'll be able to see for yourself I mean obviously it was hard I I didn't finish, so. Did not finish. Did not graduate?
必须修通识教育吗？你必须修——有后两年，你可以说，好吧，现在我想成为，呃，你知道的，呃，这个人。他们有核心要求，对吧？所以无论你学什么专业，他们都希望确保你修了教学大纲中各种不同的课程。所以你们可以自己去看看，当然它很难，我，我没能读完，所以。没读完。没毕业？
Did not graduate? No, no, no. If I were to ever, I'm still on a leap of absence, guys. It's saying over yet. OK, don't count me out. I would be a senior if I went back. You're so close. You want to go back?
没毕业？不，不，不。如果我有一天，我还在保留学籍，各位。还没结束呢。好吧，别把我排除在外。如果我回去的话，我大四了。你离毕业这么近。你想回去吗？
No, I'll go with you. All right, let's see. We can go back and do this and kind of like teach or something, and then they just give us diplomas. Yeah, we get a degree in hosting. I got a, you know, if you ever done a commencement speech, I did the commencement speech at MIT. Yeah, they don't ask for that stuff.
不，我和你一起去。好吧，咱们瞧瞧。我们可以回去把这事办了，然后当个老师什么的，接着他们就会直接给我们文凭。耶，我们拿一个主持学学位。我拿过，你知道的，如果你做过毕业典礼演讲，我在麻省理工学院做过毕业典礼演讲。对，他们才不要求那些东西呢。
You could, and they're supposed to give you, you know, Ben, I know he did one at Brown, and Ben got a diploma from Brown. Trace, that's Ben Affleck. Yup. But the great thing about that was that John Krasinski went to Brown and is very proud of that and studied and worked really hard for four years and got a diploma and Ben called him and said, I was in Rhode Island for 45 minutes and I got...
你可以，他们理应给你，你知道的，本，我知道他在布朗大学做过一次，本拿到了布朗大学的文凭。崔斯，那是本·阿弗莱克。对。但最棒的是，约翰·卡拉辛斯基去了布朗大学，对此感到非常骄傲，他认真学习，努力奋斗了四年，拿到了文凭，结果本打电话给他说，我在罗德岛待了45分钟，然后我就拿到了……
I love that. And when I gave the commencement thing at MIT, they don't give you even a really like an honorary diploma. They're like, it's MIT, like you know. You get one. So if you're not even better than that, that's cool. No school in this city gives me a diploma,
我太喜欢这个了。而且当我在麻省理工学院发表毕业演讲时，他们甚至不会真正给你一个荣誉文凭。他们会说，这里可是麻省理工，你知道的。你会拿到一个。所以如果你甚至比不上那个，那就很酷。这座城市的没有一所学校会给我文凭，
so it's fine. Hang on, what bear with me for a moment, if you give a commencement speech, you get a diploma from that year. An honorary doctorate. Doctorate. I got one of those two. Do you have to have a high school diploma before you?
所以没关系。等一下，请大家包涵我一会儿，如果你发表了毕业典礼演讲，你就能拿到那一年的文凭。一个荣誉博士学位。博士学位。我也拿过其中一个。在你……之前，你必须得有高中毕业文凭吗？
No. Ask, by the way, by the way, asking for a friend. Ask him for a friend. I'm just asking for a friend. Yeah. No, no, no, they, if you've got something they want to hear so badly, that you're considered an expert,
没有。顺便问一句，顺便问一句，我是替朋友问的。替朋友问的。我只是替朋友问的。对。不，不，不，他们，如果你有他们非常想听的内容，让你被认为是一位专家，
and you get an honorary... For God's sake, all right, so listen, what you mentioned, Ben, I don't think I know the sensor. When did you meet Ben Affleck? When and how? I was... Because we always associate you, too. I was 10 and he was 8.
你就能拿到一个荣誉……看在上帝的份上，好吧，听着，你刚才提到的，本，我觉得我不知道这个敏感词。你是什么时候认识本·阿弗莱克的？什么时候以及怎么认识的？我当时……因为我们总是把你俩联系在一起。我10岁，他8岁。
Really? Ah! And we lived two blocks from each other and I didn't know that. Yeah, we grew up together and that's why it's so weird because we didn't have anybody in our families and show business. We didn't have any, Boston isn't a show business town. It's not. Not really. You know. And we just had this weird obsession and we were probably grew up 200 yards away from each other and met each other. And just I think straight like plan.
真的吗？啊！我们俩家只隔了两条街，而我当时并不知道。对，我们是一起长大的，这就是为什么这么诡异，因为我们的家庭里都没有人在演艺圈。我们没有任何，波士顿可不是一个演艺圈城市。它不是。真的不是。你知道的。我们当时只是有一种奇怪的痴迷，而且我们可能在相距200码的地方长大，然后就认识了。而且我感觉就像是直接……按计划进行。
Yeah, we used to play little league together. We used to play. You know, he was a little younger than me. But when he got to high school, I was a junior and he was a freshman and that's when we really started hanging. And then we got agents, he had an agent, he had been on an after-school special, he had been on a, he was like the big star of a school. And was he like a big shot when he had the after-school special?
对，我们以前一起打过少棒。我们以前打过。你知道的，他比我小一点。但当他上高中时，我是高三学生，而他是高一新生，也就是在那时我们才真正开始混在一起。然后我们找了经纪人，他有一个经纪人，他上过一个课后特别节目，他上过一个，他就像是学校里的大明星。当他有了那个课后特别节目时，他是个大人物吗？
When he arrived at the high school, it was like, and I had to set him straight, because I was the lord of that theater department. And he likes to tell this story. Apparently I went up to him like first day and like pulled him up and was like, hey, you know, it's different here in the theater. Yeah. That was straight dude, right away.
当他来到那所高中时，感觉就像是，而我必须得给他立立规矩，因为我是那个戏剧部的大王。他很喜欢讲这个故事。显然我第一天就走到他面前，把他拉起来说，嘿，你知道的，在戏剧部这里情况可不一样。对。那是直接的，兄弟，马上就开始了。
You're not gonna get by in your looks. That's hilarious. We were both like five, too. That's what. What were some of the theater things? Do you still love theater? Do you want to do theater? Do you do theater?
你可不能光靠颜值混过去。太搞笑了。我们俩当时都只有五尺二寸左右。就是这样。当时有哪些戏剧活动？你还喜欢戏剧吗？你想演戏剧吗？你现在演戏剧吗？
I actually did a ton of theater in high school in college. And we had an extraordinary, amazing, amazing, amazing teacher. And it was, I mean, just from that school, me and Ben, and Casey, his brother. And I mean, there's just a ton of people who came out of that program. Sean Hader, who's just got nominated for an Oscar for Coda.
我实际上在高中和大学里演了大量的戏剧。我们有一位非凡的、了不起的、了不起的、了不起的老师。而且，我是说，仅仅从那所学校里，就走出了我和本，还有他的弟弟凯西。我的意思是，有超级多的人都是从那个项目中走出来的。肖恩·海德，她刚刚凭《健听女孩》获得奥斯卡提名。
She's the director of Coda. She went through that program. Like, there are a lot of really, because we just had this unbelievable teacher. And but I was going to say, because when I went to see you, don't keep it there. Don't keep talking. Keep talking.
她就是《健听女孩》的导演。她就是从那个项目里出来的。比如，有非常多的人，因为我们当时有这样一位不可思议的老师。而且我本想说的是，因为当我去——别停在那儿。别停下来讲。继续讲。
When I went to see you on Broadway, and I had done a play in London 20 years ago, and with KCF like actually and I went to, you know, 10 years later or whatever, which is probably 10 years ago when was it when? Yeah, 2010. 2010. Was this promises promises? It was promises promises. And so we were a pause pad. It was, and obviously he was amazing. And great. It was, it was awesome. And we, we see it, and we were totally into it.
当我去百老汇看你演出时，20年前我在伦敦演过一出戏，实际上是和凯西一起去的，然后我去了，你知道的，10年后还是什么时候，可能也就是10年前，那是什么时候？对，2010年。2010年。那是《承诺，承诺》吗？那是《承诺，承诺》。所以我们俩是一个……那是一部，显然他演得很棒。而且很棒。那部剧，那部剧太棒了。我们，我们看了，我们完全沉浸其中。
It was deep into the run now. And we went backstage and I have never seen a more, it made me never want to do theater again. I looked at you and you were just, we're like, I'm, you were, you were, I was like, hey, it's going on high. He was, Scott, he just had his hand around. He was just holding you up.
当时演出已经进行到很长一段时间了。我们去了后台，我从来没见过比这更累的，它让我再也不想演戏剧了。我看着你，你就好像，我们就像是，我，你当时，你当时，我当时在想，嘿，情况不太妙。他当时，斯科特，他正把手搭在你身上。他只是在扶着你。
You were like, it shows a week. Who would do this? Yeah. You were so tired. It was awful. And you still have like a month and a half to go. Yeah, it was an end of the finish line. But you were so nice to come A and B to see the show.
你当时就像是，一周要演好几场。谁会干这事啊？对。你当时太累了。太惨了。而且你离终点线居然还有一个半月。对，那是临近终点线的时候。但你人真的很好，A是来看演出，B是来看演出。
And the B to you wore those, I sent you a long time ago, as a birthday gift, shirts, t-shirts with my picture on it. Oh, that's right. And you wore it through the show. That's right. Oh my God. Oh my God. I forgot that.
而且作为B，你穿着那些我很久以前送给你的作为生日礼物的衬衫，印着我头像的T恤。哦，对哦。而且你整个演出期间都穿着它。没错。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我把这事给忘了。
I totally forgot about that. Yeah. I didn't have that shirt in that. It had holes in it. Because I did it, because you know those shirts that you wash so many times, they're better than it. So that was my Sean Hay shirt. Yeah.
我完全把这事给忘了。对。我那件衬衫没有那个。上面都有洞了。因为我穿过，因为你知道那些你洗过无数次的衬衫，它们穿起来比新的还要舒服。所以那是我的肖恩·海(衬衫)。对。
That was like, didn't it say something what did you write there was some great it was really funny I can't believe I can't remember I probably sure more or 600 times but no no you were so sweet and I too get better as more the more you wash me I get would you what about you ever done musicals no yes yes really of course what do you think I'm a guy in this Have you ever done musicals? No, yes. Really? Of course. Hang on.
就像是，上面是不是写了什么，你写了什么来着，有一些很棒的字，真的很好笑，我简直不敢相信我不记得了，我可能穿过600多次吧，不，不，你太贴心了，而且我也一样，你洗我越多我就变得越好，你会，那你呢，你演过音乐剧吗？没有，有，真的吗？当然，你觉得我是什么人啊？你演过音乐剧吗？没有，有。真的吗？当然。等一下。
Oh my god, in high school. Pippin? I was Pippin. No, fuck yeah. Yeah, I totally have. Everybody has it's time. Show me a reason. Show you a rhyme.
哦，天哪，在高中时。Pippin（彼品）？我演过彼品。不，操，当然。对，我绝对演过。每个人都有过那个时候。给我一个理由。给你一个韵脚。
Oh my god. I literally, I sing that to my daughter to drive her. I do, I do, with the choreography we did, it was like, it was literally like, it was like, I think it's that. It was like, it was like, rivers belong where they can ramble. Eagles belong.
哦，天哪。我真的，我唱这个给我女儿听来折磨她。我唱过，我唱过，配上我们当时做的舞蹈动作，就像是，它真的就像是，它就像是，我觉得是这样的。就像是，就像是，河流属于它们可以漫游的地方。老鹰属于……
That was literally the choreography. So that's my kryptonite, I can't sing in the shower even. I mean, I would kill either. I can't sing either. I think that's my kryptonite. I can't sing in the shower even. I mean, I would kill him. I can't sing either. Yes, I can't sing it pretty good. That's a really good Jason just admitted today that he hasn't danced since when? What happened?
这真的是当时的编舞。所以那是我的软肋，我甚至在淋浴时都不能唱歌。我是说，我也会杀了谁。我也不会唱歌。我觉得那是我的软肋。我甚至在淋浴时都不能唱歌。我是说，我也会杀了谁。我也不会唱歌。是的，我唱得其实挺好的。杰森今天刚刚承认他从什么时候开始就没跳过舞了？怎么回事？
I have a, yeah, I had a fourth grade dance. And I made my sister teach me a dance step all night to like midnight. And it was just, it was this one. And I just so I got to the dance with with my girlfriend Amy Keating and I did that for about four or five songs and then she stopped in the middle of the sixth song and said is that the only step you know and she left she left the floor. And I've never danced since. Now, the follow up to that is, I ran into a friend of mine who,
我有一个，对，我上四年级时有个舞会。我让我姐姐整晚教我一个舞步，一直教到差不多半夜。就是这个动作。然后我带着女朋友艾米·基廷去参加舞会，这一个动作我跳了差不多四五首歌，接着她在第六首歌跳到一半时停了下来，说：“难道你就只会这一个舞步吗？”然后她就走了，她离开了舞池。
10 years later, 15 years later, we were in the class together with Amy. And we were talking about her, and he said, he said, you know, I heard she got a brain tumor. And I said, oh my God, is she okay? He says, I don't know. But I hear she may have not made it. And I was tumor and I said, oh my God. Is she okay? He says I don't know But I hear she may have not made it and I was like, oh God no, no cut to She I get an email from Amy Keating about five years later saying hey, just wanted to reach out. I hear you think I'm dead
从那以后我再也没跳过舞。现在，这件事的后续是，我碰巧遇到了一个朋友，10年后，15年后，我们和艾米一起上过课。我们在聊起她时，他说，他说道：“你知道吗，我听说她得了脑瘤。”我说：“哦，天哪，她没事吧？”他说：“我不知道。但我听说她可能没挺过去。”而我当时听到肿瘤的消息时说：“哦，天哪。她没事吧？”他说“我不知道，但我听说她可能没挺过去”而我当时想，“哦，老天，不，不”，镜头一转，大约五年后我收到了艾米·基廷的一封邮件，上面写着：“嘿，只是想联系一下。我听说你觉得我死了。”
And she said she said so I've made a documentary that says Jason Bateman thinks I'm dead. And I'd like to interview you for the end of the documentary. Would you come meet me at the auditorium where I left the stage at our elementary school so I can interview you. And I was like, yeah, and I sat down for an interview and I think it's on YouTube. This documentary. Wait, what? Oh my god. Jason, baby, things I'm dead by you, baby kitty. It's a true story.
她说，她说：“所以，我制作了一部纪录片，片名叫《杰森·贝特曼以为我死了》。我想在纪录片的结尾采访你。你愿意来我们小学的礼堂，也就是我当年离开舞台的地方见我吗，这样我就可以采访你了。”当时我就想：“好啊。”我坐下来接受了采访，我想这部纪录片现在还在YouTube上。等等，什么？哦，天哪。《杰森·贝特曼以为我死了》，作者艾米·基廷。这是一个真实的故事。
How have we never heard about this? I've not told that story? No. The fuck are you talking about? That's crazy. I've got many stories. All right, ready? Here we go.
我们怎么从来没听说过这个？我没讲过这个故事吗？没有。你他妈在说什么？太疯狂了。我有好多故事呢。好了，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。
Oh, god. I want to start at the beginning. No, uh, I want to, I know you had probably had, first of all, I have to state the obvious, which is you're one of the biggest fucking stars in the planet, right? Right. It's true. I don't know that's not important to you.
哦，天哪。我想从头说起。不，呃，我想，我知道你可能经历过，首先，我必须说一个显而易见的事实，那就是你是地球上最红的超级巨星之一，对吧？对。这是真的。我不知道这对于你来说并不是最重要的。
And I know, I know the art and the craft of it is more important than any of that, but it's just to you. And I know the art and the craft of it is more important than any of that. But it's just so cool. It's just so cool, right? And we're all such fans. I love you, and I've been such a fan as well. And I mean, how hard did we laugh? He did this episode of Will and Grace, where he played.
我知道，我知道表演的艺术和技艺比所有这些都更重要，但对你而言就是如此。我知道表演的艺术和技艺比所有这些都更重要。但这真的很酷。这真的很酷，对吧？我们所有人都是你的粉丝。我爱你，我一直以来也是你的超级粉丝。我的意思是，我们笑得有多开心啊？你客串过一集《威尔与格蕾丝》，你在里面扮演……
He played this guy. That was the funniest. I mean, by the way, I have a quick start. You don't know this thing. He played this guy who was actually pretended to be gay so we could sing in the gay man's chorus. Because they were going to Europe, and he wanted the free trip to Europe.
你扮演了这个家伙。那一集太搞笑了。顺便说一句，我有一个快速开场。你不知道这件事。他扮演的这个家伙实际上是假装是个同性恋，这样他就能加入同性恋男子合唱团。因为他们要去欧洲巡演，而他想要一趟免费的欧洲之旅。
Right. It was such a stupid thing. It was so funny, though. Did you sing on the show? Yeah, he did. We all in the chorus. We all sang. But the whole idea was that Sean, he figures it out.
对。这事太蠢了。不过真的超级搞笑。你在剧里唱歌了吗？对，唱了。我们在合唱团里。我们都唱了。但整个情节是肖恩发现了。
Yeah, I'm like, you're straight. And so he tries to in me. Right. Instead, yeah, out. Right. But the show was like 10 years deep. And I had never done a sitcom. And I couldn't believe, like, so fun.
对，我说：“你其实是直男。”于是他试图让我出柜。对。反而是，对，出柜。对。但当时那部情景喜剧已经播了大约10年了。而我从来没演过情景喜剧。我简直不敢相信，太有趣了。
Because they were so locked in. And the writers were so locked in, and the writers were so locked. I'm amazed. Like that table, like you'd sit around. The first draft comes in, we read it. It's hysterical. And then there's like 10 of you, and you guys just start going. And you make it better and better and better.
因为他们配合得太默契了。编剧们配合得太默契了，编剧们配合得太默契了。我太惊叹了。就像那张剧本围读桌，你坐在周围。初稿一出来，我们读了一遍。爆笑如雷。然后你们大约有10个人，大家就开始即兴发挥了。你们把它改得越来越好、越来越好。
And it was just so fun. And I couldn't believe how, by that point, because you put all the work in for 10 years, how little you guys worked. I was like, oh, shit. It's amazing. It's incredible. Well, James Burrow is one of the greatest directors of all time.
这真的太有趣了。我简直不敢相信，到那个时候，因为你们已经为此付出了10年的努力，你们的工作量居然那么少。当时我想：“哦，操。”这太神奇了。太不可思议了。嗯，詹姆斯·伯罗斯是有史以来最伟大的导演之一。
He directed every episode of Cheers, every episode of Will & Grace. He directed Friends, Taxi, Big Bang Theory, Two and a half men, all these things. But anyway, he's got me like this, right? So now, and I got spoiled at such a young age, so now when I'm on a set, I'm like, what's taken so long, you know? But you're so sweet because I remember you don't know this, I think, or maybe you do. But during that episode, you were so kind and worried,
他导演了每一集的《欢乐酒店》，每一集的《威尔与格蕾丝》。他导演了《老友记》、《出租车》、《生活大爆炸》、《好汉两个半》以及所有这些剧。但不管怎样，他把我弄成这样，对吧？所以现在，我在这么年轻的时候就被惯坏了，因此现在当我在片场时，我会想：“怎么花了这么长时间？”你知道的。但你真的太贴心了，因为我记得——你可能不知道这件事，或者你可能知道。但在拍那一集的时候，你非常善良并且很担心，
like nobody was attending to your hair or something, and you had a baseball hat on all day. So you took it off, and I think you were afraid to ask for help. So in the episode, you can see the line where it's had is By the way, there it is today. I have the same line If I'm left to my own devices, I'm just completely Like fine to build on that real quick the the the kindness that you have is so authentic and sincere and organic and
好像没有人帮你弄头发之类的，而且你一整天都戴着一顶棒球帽。所以你把它摘了下来，我猜你当时不好意思寻求帮助。所以在那一集里，你可以看到那条台词……顺便说一句，今天它就在那儿。我有同样的台词：如果任由我自由发挥，我就会完全，就像，完全可以以此为基础迅速推进，你所拥有的那种善良是如此地真实、真诚、纯粹，而且
We are in such a permissive business for bad behavior. And then if you're super famous, they let you get away with even worse stuff. What is it that keeps you from behaving badly? Beyond just your own naturalistic, was your mom or your dad real good at like saying things just starting to really take off for your son, keep your shit together together or did you have like a bend that would like beat the crap out of you like you did with him and Matt let me just say before you answer Jason wants to know why aren't you giving into your desire to be shitty to people because he finds it really hard to bury it how do you bury it right is it similar to how
我们身处这样一个对不良行为极其宽容的行业里。而且如果你超级有名，他们甚至会让你逃脱更糟糕的事情。是什么让你克制自己不去表现得很糟糕？除了你天生的性格之外，你的妈妈或者爸爸是不是很擅长说一些诸如“事情刚开始有起色，你要稳住阵脚”之类的话，还是说你有一个像本那样会把你揍得屁滚尿流的人，就像你对付他和马特那样？在我回答之前，请允许我先说一句：杰森想知道，你为什么不向自己想要对别人刻薄的欲望妥协？因为他发现要把这种欲望压抑下去真的很难，你是怎么把它压抑下去的？这和他的压抑方式类似吗？请说吧。
he buries it go ahead yeah I Yeah, man, I don't know. I never had an impulse to do that. I don't know why. I think I just was lucky. I think I had a great parents, a great big brother, and a great foundation. And I honestly, you guys all know. You lost it at some point.
对，伙计，我不知道。我从来没有过那种冲动。我不知道为什么。我想我只是比较幸运。我想我有一对伟大的父母、一个伟大的大哥和一个很好的成长基础。老实说，你们大家都知道。你曾在某个时刻失控过。
I think the experience of getting famous is weird. And I always reflected back on that after I kind of got through that first two years. Like, whoa, that was crazy. And you're working with people and you're seeing people that are more famous than you coming up, the way they're acting, which for the most part is not great.
我认为成名的经历是很诡异的。在我熬过头两年之后，我总是会回想起那段经历。心想：“哇，那太疯狂了。”你会和一些人合作，看到那些比你更出名的新人，他们做事的方式，大多数情况下其实并不好。
And how did you think like, you know, well, I guess I gotta be a dickhead. I've been really, really lucky. Oh good. I have not witnessed a lot of bad behavior. I really, I started out, I guess I gotta be a dickhead. I've been really, really lucky. Oh, good. I have not witnessed a lot of bad behavior. Really? I started out. I was working with, I had like, Denzel and Robin Williams
当时你怎么会觉得，你知道的，“好吧，我想我也得当个混蛋。”我真的，真的非常幸运。哦，太好了。我没有目睹过太多糟糕的行为。我真的，我刚开始时，我想我也得当个混蛋。我真的，真的非常幸运。哦，太好了。我没有目睹过太多糟糕的行为。真的吗？我刚出道的时候。我合作的都是，我有丹泽尔和罗宾·威廉姆斯
and Tom Hanks and these people who were like, so, and nobody was bigger than them, right? And they were so classy and professional and kind and good and like, it's good and like important first examples Yeah, I mean, it just really set the tone I always say if you can't find the asshole on the set It's probably you the asshole. Yeah So You mentioned your big brother. How many how many siblings you have just one?
还有汤姆·汉克斯这样的人，他们是那样的，而且没有人比他们更大牌了，对吧？他们是那样的风度翩翩、专业、善良又优秀，就像，这很好，而且是很重要的第一课。对，我是说，这真的奠定了基调。我总是说，如果你在片场找不到那个混蛋，那那个混蛋可能就是你。对。所以你提到了你的大哥。你有几个兄弟姐妹？只有一个。
Just one how much older is he the three years older? You guys still really tight. Oh, yeah What sort of without getting specific what line of work is he he's an artist? No way. Yeah, well like painter painter in a scope there. Yeah, can I buy some of his stuff? Which is certainly good. Yes, really? I would love to talk afterwards How funny I don't know this either so your parents in the arts or no no no my mom's the professor of early childhood education Yeah, and No, no, my mom's the professor of early childhood education. Wow. Yeah. And my dad was, when I was a kid, he was a stock broker.
只有一个。他比你大多少？大三岁。你们现在关系还是很好吗？哦，对。没有具体问的话，他从事什么行业？他是艺术家。不会吧。对，就像画家、雕塑家那种。对。我能买一些他的作品吗？那当然很棒。真的吗？我很想结束后聊聊。真搞笑，我也对此一无所知。所以你的父母是搞艺术的吗？不是，不是。我妈妈是幼儿教育学的教授。对。不，不，我妈妈是幼儿教育学的教授。哇。对。我爸爸，在我小时候，他是个股票经纪人。
He taught school. He did all kinds of jobs until he finally built a company and became really successful and retired early. But it was interesting because my mom did what she loved and didn't get paid anything. And my dad only did what he did just to make sure that we were provided for and he never enjoyed his work. And so it was a great lesson, I think, for my brother and me to go, because both of them were saying
他教过书。他做过各种各样的工作，直到他最终创立了一家公司，取得了巨大的成功并提前退休了。但这段经历很有趣，因为我妈妈做着她热爱的事却拿不到什么钱；而我爸爸做他的工作，仅仅是为了确保我们的生活有着落，他从来没有享受过他的工作。所以，我想这对于我和我哥哥来说是一个很好的教训，因为他们两个
from two different sides of the coin, like follow what you love to do. And it's awesome. And so it's probably great to have a brother who's an artist, even though he's not an actor or director or writer or whatever. to do and yeah that's awesome and so it's probably great to have a brother who's an artist even though he's not an actor or director or writer or whatever but because he's an artist he can you guys can talk a similar language and relate as creative people yeah I love I mean I really trust his judgment and his opinions and I mean you guys know like when you're working
从硬币的两面分别告诉我们：去追随你热爱的事业。这太棒了。所以，有一个身为艺术家的哥哥一定很棒，尽管他不是演员、导演、作家什么的。去追求它，是的，这太棒了。所以有一个身为艺术家的哥哥一定很棒，尽管他不是演员、导演、作家或别的什么，但正因为他是艺术家，你们俩可以使用相通的语言，作为富有创造力的人产生共鸣。是的，我喜欢，我是说我真的非常信任他的判断力和意见。我的意思是，你们也知道，当你们在工作时，
I mean it's like you you have a little core group of people that you show your stuff to and you're like am I crazy or is this like, am I crazy? Or is this working? Or am I crazy? Is Lucy straight with you? Was she tell you when you suck? She. Yes. Lucy. And she's been actually, for me, really the best bell weather. Tracy.
我的意思是，就像你有一个核心小圈子，你会把你的作品拿给他们看，然后你会想：我是疯了还是这——我是疯了还是这行得通？还是我疯了？露西对你坦诚吗？她会告诉你你演得很烂吗？她会。是的。露西。而且对我来说，她真的是最好的风向标。崔西。
Lucy is. Tell Tracy who Lucy is. Is Tracy. Lucy is my wife. By the way, speed of trade. Like, I didn't know. I was standing next to Tracy and the wings trying to hide. I didn't know it was Tracy.
露西是。告诉崔西露西是谁。崔西就是。露西是我的妻子。顺便说一句，说到崔西。就像，我当时不知道。我正站在侧幕条的崔西旁边试图躲起来。我当时不知道那是崔西。
Oh, really? And then I'm sitting there, I'm like, what'd they say? You know? And I'm just, I just, because there's, you know, 10 people back there and I figured they're all working on the show. Right. And suddenly you announce that she goes blasting out, I'm like, oh shit, that was Tracy. Well, I was solely star-struck, but I better. Yeah.
哦，真的吗？然后我坐在那儿，心想：“他们在说什么呢？”你知道的？我只是，我只是，因为那里，你知道的，后面有10个人，我以为他们都是剧组的工作人员。对。然后你突然宣布她从后台冲了出来，我当时想：“哦，操，那是崔西。”嗯，我当时完全被大明星迷住了，不过我也算。对。
That's a thing. Okay, so wait, I want to talk about, you know, I know you're so sick of talking. You have typed questions. You know what? Sean is a bit curious, by the way. Sean, for sure. That is harder than you worked on that episode of Willing
这也是一回事。好吧，等等，我想谈谈，我知道你已经厌倦了谈论。你打过字提问。你知道吗？顺便说一句，肖恩其实挺好奇的。肖恩绝对是的。那可比你在那一集《威尔与格蕾丝》里付出的工作还要辛苦。
Scott. Without a doubt. It's so true. And I made so much money. Sean is so organized. One of the things we're finding on this tour. Oh my god. Sean is insane.
斯科特。毫无疑问。确实如此。而且我赚了好多钱。肖恩太有条理了。我们在这次巡演中发现的一件事是。哦，天哪。肖恩简直太疯狂了。
So the other night we got back to New York, we got back after the show, and we all had dinner in our room, and it's us and a bunch of people and our friends. And so everybody's got food. They're like eight or ten of us. The food arrives, we start eating. Sean's finished in, I don't know,
所以前天晚上我们回到纽约，演出结束后我们回到了酒店，大家都在房间里吃了晚餐。我们在场有一群人，还有我们的朋友。所以每个人都有了食物。我们大约有八到十个人。食物送到了，我们开始吃。肖恩吃完，我不知道，
legitimately 90 seconds, maybe two minutes. And everybody else is just starting their food and he stands up and he starts, he clears his plate and then he starts clearing all the loose ends and then he starts clearing plate, like, you're like, no, no, I'm not done yet. What? Right?
合理地说也就是90秒，最多两分钟。当其他人的食物才刚刚开始吃时，他站了起来，他开始，他清理了自己的盘子，然后他开始清理所有的残局，然后他开始清理盘子，就像，你会说：“不，不，我还没吃完呢。”什么？对吧？
It's just cleaning. It's just cleaning. Now this is a hotel room. There are people who are gonna come and clean it anyway, but no, he's cleaning it. But that's my wife does this exact same thing. It drives me crazy. It's bonkers, man.
这只是在打扫。这只是在打扫。而且这是一个酒店房间。本来也会有人来打扫的，但不行，他就是要清理。不过我妻子也会做一模一样的事。这快把我逼疯了。这太荒谬了，伙计。
I'm like, why are you busing the table? I'm eating my food. I'm like, he likes order, he doesn't like chaos, he likes things done tight in the proper way. We're being driven here in a tinny tour bus. Yeah. And he's got ways open to make sure the driver is on the right route.
我就想：“你为什么要收拾桌子？我还在吃我的饭呢。”我心想：他喜欢秩序，他不喜欢混乱，他喜欢事情以正确的方式做到极致。我们现在正坐在一辆狭窄的巡演大巴里被载着前行。对。而他一直开着导航应用，以确保司机走的是正确的路线。
And so we keep going every three times we go, how much longer, Sean, he's like, at three minutes. And he's like, I'm starting a new app. It's not called ways. It's called gaze. It's much faster. It's much faster. It's much faster.
所以每隔三次我们就会问：“还要多久啊，肖恩？”他就会说：“还有三分钟。”然后他说：“我要开发一个新的应用程序。不叫Waze（导航软件），叫Gaze（凝视）。快得多。快得多。快得多。”
Yeah, it's much faster. It's much faster. It's much faster. Yeah, it's much faster. Oh, the more handsome font. Yeah. We'll be right back. Hey, smartless listener. We get support from a viator. Experiences are what people love the most about travel. They create long-lasting memories
对，快得多。快得多。快得多。对，快得多。哦，字体更帅气。对。我们马上回来。嘿，SmartLess的听众朋友们。我们得到了Viator的大力支持。旅行中最让人喜爱的莫过于各种体验。它们能创造出持久的记忆，
that make memories and connections that will last well beyond the trip. Viator is the place to go to book memorable travel experiences. They offer everything from simple tours to extreme adventures and all the niche interesting stuff in between. I don't know about you,
创造出超越旅行本身的记忆与连结。Viator正是预订难忘旅行体验的绝佳去处。他们提供从简单的观光旅游到极限探险，以及介于两者之间的各种小众有趣项目。我不知道你们怎么样，
but you look for opportunities to bond with your kids because when you're at home, they're busy doing their stuff with their school and their kids and the blah, blah, blah, blah, and they don't want to talk to mom and dad. You get them on some cool trip. You get all these great experiences, lifelong memories, nice bonding.
但你总是在寻找与孩子们建立亲密关系的机会，因为当你在家时，他们忙着应付学校和同龄人的各种事情，喋喋不休，根本不想跟爸爸妈妈说话。如果你带他们来一场酷炫的旅行。你们就能收获所有这些美妙的体验、终生难忘的回忆，还能增进感情。
It's a key for us. Now, when you book a travel experience with Viator, there's always flexibility and support with free cancellation, payment options, and 24-7 service. Plus, Viator has over 300,000 bookable experiences to choose from in over 190 countries. So there's something for everyone.
这对我们来说是关键所在。现在，当你通过Viator预订旅行体验时，总能享受到免费取消、灵活的付款方式以及全天候服务的灵活性与保障。此外，Viator在190多个国家/地区拥有超过30万种可预订的体验供你选择。所以总有一款适合每个人。
It makes sense. Download the Viator app now and use code Viator10 for 10% off your first booking. 1 app. Over 300,000 experiences you will remember. Do more with Viator. Today, we're working and communicating more quickly than ever, and sometimes we can feel stuck. Give yourself a helping hand with Grammarly Go. Grammarly's new communication assistant powered by Generative AI. Grammarly Go understands your unique context, preferred voice, and goals to quickly generate
这就对了。立即下载Viator应用，并在首次预订时使用代码Viator10即可享受9折优惠。1个应用。超过30万种让你铭记的体验。与Viator一起体验更多。今天，我们工作和沟通的速度比以往任何时候都要快，有时我们会感到陷入困境。使用Grammarly Go为自己提供一个得力的助手。Grammarly推出的全新沟通助手，由生成式人工智能驱动。Grammarly Go能够理解你独特的语境、偏好的语气和目标，从而快速生成
high quality writing, which is a few clicks, you can ideate, compose, rewrite, and reply thoughtfully, struggling with new ideas, input a prompt, and Grammarly Go will generate innovative suggestions to help you move your ideas forward. So for me, a few weeks ago, I got emergency laser surgery on one of my eyes, and I couldn't read or write. So all I could do is dictate or speak into it. So what Grammarly Go did for me was help me kind of outline a speech
高质量的文字。只需点击几下，你就可以构思、撰写、重写和深思熟虑地回复。如果你在寻找新创意时遇到困难，只需输入一个提示，Grammarly Go就会产生创新的建议，帮助你推进想法。所以对我来说，几周前，我的一只眼睛做了紧急激光手术，我无法阅读或写作。所以我能做的就是口述或对着它说话。所以Grammarly Go为我做的是帮我勾勒出一个演讲的提纲，
that I had to give and then Scotty filled in the rest and it came out terrific. Because Scotty is also based on AI. He's generated. He's not even real. Scott Tash, he is his name. You'll be amazed at what you can do with Grammarly Go. Go to Grammarly.com slash go to download and learn more about Grammarly Go. That's g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y.com slash go. In the first part of the 20th century, the Hilton family had a luck on the hotel industry by offering upscaled service at a modest price. The company was expanding fast and buying up iconic properties across the country, like the Plaza and the Waldorf Astoria. But their unchallenged rise wouldn't last.
我必须发表这个演讲，然后斯科特填补了其余的内容，效果好极了。因为斯科特也是基于人工智能的。他是生成出来的。他甚至都不是真人。他的名字叫斯科特·塔什。你会对Grammarly Go能做的事情感到惊叹。前往Grammarly.com/go下载并了解更多关于Grammarly Go的信息。网址是 g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y.com/go。在20世纪的上半叶，希尔顿家族通过以适度的价格提供高端服务，在酒店行业占据了一席之地。该公司扩张迅速，并在全国范围内收购了标志性的物业，如广场酒店和华尔道夫酒店。但他们未受挑战的崛起并不会持续下去。
An ambitious Mormon named JW Marriott decides to pivot from restaurants to hospitality, and he's after Hilton's business, developing modern hotels across the world. But both the Hilton and Marriott families will have to contend with their share of drama in finding a successor, while also fighting to stay solvent in a high-stakes business. Hi, I'm David Brown, the host of Wonderree Show Business Wars. We go deep into some of the biggest corporate rivalries of all time. In our latest season, Hilton and Marriott are in a race to expand globally and secure the loyalty of fickle customers. Make sure to follow business wars wherever you get your podcasts.
一个雄心勃勃的摩门教徒名叫JW·马riott，决定从餐饮业转型为酒店业，他紧追希尔顿的业务，在世界各地开发现代化的酒店。但希尔顿和马riott家族都将不得不应对他们在寻找继承人过程中的各种戏剧性事件，同时还要在竞争激烈的商业环境中挣扎求生。嗨，我是大卫·布朗，Wondery节目《商战》的主持人。我们将深入剖析史上一些最大的企业竞争。在我们最新的季度中，希尔顿和马riott正在竞相全球扩张，以确保变化无常的客户的忠诚度。请务必在您获取播客的任何地方关注《商战》。
You can listen ad-free on the Amazon Music or Wondery app. And now back to the show. All right, so now I know you're sick of talking about good, well-hunting and just just bear with me here because I, you know, because I have every single one of your movies, like it's crazy. But talk about, you know, what I love about this story me here because I have every single one of your movies. It's crazy.
您可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery应用程序上收听无广告版。现在回到节目中。好的，现在我知道你已经厌倦了谈论《心灵捕手》了，请大家暂时包涵我一下，因为我，你知道的，因为我有你的每一部电影，简直太疯狂了。但是谈谈，你知道的，我喜欢这个故事的……请包涵我一下，因为我有你的每一部电影。这太疯狂了。
But talk about what I love about this story, about how it happened, because so many people ask, how do I start? Where do I, like, what did you do? How did you get your start? And you just fucking did it. You're like, well, I want to work. I want to work. So maybe I should just write my own thing, right?
但谈谈我为什么喜欢这个故事，关于它是如何发生的，因为有太多人问：我该如何开始？我该在哪里，比如，你们是怎么做的？你们是怎么起步的？而你们他妈的就直接把它做出来了。你们就好像：嗯，我想工作。我想工作。所以也许我应该自己写剧本，对吧？
And then want an Oscar for that script. Yeah, I mean, it worked out. Yeah, yeah. The only reason I love for you to just talk, yeah, exactly. For you to tell it is because there are my first step at. I worked out. There are so many people who want, and you know, so many young people starting out that love this story.
然后凭那个剧本获得了奥斯卡奖。对，我是说，结果成功了。对，对。我希望你谈谈的唯一原因，是的，正是如此。由你来讲述是因为有我的第一步。成功了。有那么多的人想要，你知道的，有那么多刚起步的年轻人热爱这个故事。
That need to hear the same. I mean, I think we were, A, desperate, we were unemployed, struggling actors and it just became clear that we were going to have to wait forever until we got a shot. And I remember it was that movie Primal Fear. I don't know if you- I was just waiting out on our next report. Right.
需要听到这个。我的意思是，我想我们当时，A，很绝望，我们是失业、苦苦挣扎的演员，情况已经很清楚了，如果我们一直等下去，可能永远也等不到一个机会。我记得那是电影《一级恐惧》。我不知道你们——我当时正等着我们的下一篇报道。对。
Ed Norton and Richard Geer. Yeah. Edward, you know, brilliant actor, you know, my age, Edward got the part and what, and was great. I think he got nominated for an Oscar's in the movie. So that script came along and Ben and I looked at it and we were like, that's the best role. I was like, why isn't a movie star taking this role? This is an unbelievable role. Like why isn't like at the time it was like Ethan Hawke or Robert Sean Letter, all the
爱德华·诺顿和理查·基尔。对，爱德华，你知道的，才华横溢的演员，跟我同龄，爱德华得到了那个角色，而且，很棒。我想他因为那部电影获得了奥斯卡提名。所以那个剧本出现了，本和我看了之后觉得，那是最好的角色。当时我想：为什么没有哪个电影明星来演这个角色？这是一个令人难以置信的角色。比如，为什么当时的伊桑·霍克或者罗伯特·肖恩·利奥纳德，所有那些
guys from Deadpool, it's like, why aren't those guys jumping all over this? This thing is amazing. And I bought ice-paid for a dialect coach because remember he switches these two for- I would feel money. I'm the take-in to get a dialect coach. But this was like, with money I didn't have because I was like, this is it. You know what I mean? You prepare for the audition.
死侍里的家伙，为什么那些家伙不一拥而上呢？这东西太棒了。我买了一个——我自掏腰包请了一位方言教练，因为你记得他要在两个之间切换——我当时花了真金白银。我是为了弄到一个方言教练而花钱。但这就像是用我根本没有的钱，因为当时我想：就是这个了。你知道我的意思吗？你为试镜做准备。
To prepare for the audition. And he switches from southern to normal or normal to Southern. Yeah, exactly, exactly. It's like a jackal and hide thing. I don't know what I'm talking about. Do you say Southern to normal? No. Oh, God.
为了试镜做准备。然后他在南方口音和普通口音之间切换，或者从普通口音切换到南方口音。对，没错，没错。这就像是化身博士的故事。我不知道自己在胡说些什么。你刚刚说的是从南方口音切到普通口音吗？没有。哦，天哪。
Oh, God. Oh, God. Standard, maybe, standard. That plays, OK, that plays well in Wisconsin, OK? Yeah. What's not Southern? Yeah. What's that? Wisconsin. I said it plays well because you, okay? But what's not Southern? What's that? Wisconsin.
哦，天哪。哦，天哪。标准口音，也许吧，标准口音。这在威斯康星州挺吃香的，好吧？对。什么不叫南方口音？对。那是什么？威斯康星州。我刚刚说它挺吃香是因为你，好吧？但什么不叫南方口音？那是什么？威斯康星州。
I said it plays well because you just called them normal. No, no, they're, they're, they're all really nervous for you right now. Yeah. I think I got canceled a minute five. I just poured cement over it and yeah. Everybody's nervous at every moment. That's the best. You guys are so rough.
我说它挺吃香是因为你刚才管这叫正常口音。不，不，他们，他们，他们现在都为你捏了一把汗。对。我想我在第五分钟就被取消资格了。我刚在上面浇了一层水泥，然后，对。每个人在每一刻都提心吊胆的。这太棒了。你们太刻薄了。
I'm terrified for you, buddy. I had to be honest. Hi. That was... But he does... He does... Does he go into the country? The country just got cut in half.
兄弟，我真替你捏一把汗。老实说。嗨。那是……但他的确……他的确……他去乡村了吗？乡村刚才被劈成两半了。
Yeah. You can't. You can only go to half the country now. So easy. Where do you guys shoot, Ozark? Oh, oh. Oh, oh. Southern.
对。你不能去了。你现在只能去半个国家了。太轻松了。你们在哪里拍《黑钱胜地》？哦，哦。哦，哦。南方。
Atlanta. So he has a Southern accent. No, so you have a switch between Ozark and Norma. Yeah. Yeah. So. Oh. So yeah. Oh, God bless.
亚特兰大。所以他有南方口音。不，所以你得在《黑钱胜地》口音和普通口音之间切换。对。对。所以。哦。所以，对。哦，上帝保佑。
But the idea was that there are two distinctive voices that come from this guy. Yes. Both perfectly good voices. Yes. Yes. Two excellent distinctive voices because he's playing and having a mental health problem. He's saying he's schizophrenic and then there's a whole, but it's an actor's dream because he's really showcasing part of this, whoever got it.
但当时的想法是，这个家伙身上有两种截然不同的声音。是的。两种完全合格的声音。是的。是的。两个出色且截然不同的声音，因为他在扮演一个有心理健康问题的人。他说他患有精神分裂症，然后还有整套剧情，但这对演员来说简直是个梦想，因为他真正展现了这部分内容，无论谁演的话。
And Edward won the part, but Ben and I realized then we were like, what are the odds of another movie coming down, and then it gets kicked down and there's 10,000 of us, like rabbit hyenas are going for it And like what are the chances of a another one's gonna come in the next five years and be that even if it does Will be the ones to get it. We'll get called back. We'll get close remember. Oh, you don't remember audition Yes, I do I do You were a fucking star when you were like eight and I was watching you like that guy I could do that when you were like eight. No.
最后爱德华拿到了这个角色，但本和我当时意识到，我们心想：另一部剧本出现并被搁置，然后有1万个人像饿狼鬣狗一样扑上去，这种几率到底有多大？而且在接下来的五年里，再有一部剧本出现并且达到这种水平的几率会有多大？就算有，难道会轮到我们去演吗？我们会接到回调通知的。我们会接近成功，记得吗？哦，你不记得试镜了吗？对，我记得，我记得。你八岁的时候就是个他妈的明星了，我看着你心想：那家伙能做到。我八岁的时候也能做到。不。
And I was watching you like, that guy could do that. I could do that. But, uh, but yeah, we, we, so that kind of started us thinking about writing, about going like, well, let's write our own part. Why don't you go to do yourself? Yeah. You were dying to be an actor, not a writer.
而且我看着你心想：那家伙能做到。我也可以。但是，呃，但是，呃，我们，我们，所以这让我们开始考虑写作，心想：好吧，让我们写我们自己的角色吧。你为什么不自己去演呢？对。你当时极度渴望成为一名演员，而不是作家。
Right. Right. We were writing just literally to give us. Because you went on to stop for writing. That's amazing. I know. I'm scared. I've us. You went on to stop for writing. That's a man's song. I know. I've never gotten any award of any kind for acting. Now, what about...
对。对。我们写作纯粹是为了给我们自己提供角色。因为你后来就不再演戏专职写作了。这太神奇了。我懂。我好怕。我们……你后来就不再演戏专职写作了。那真是一首男人的歌。我懂。我从来没有因为演戏而获得过任何种类的奖项。那么……
What about... Wait, it's actually... There was a... I got the Empire Magazine gave me an award in like 2007. And I went and picked up the award. Yeah. I was like, guys, like in high school we had the Massachusetts High School Drama Festival, and picked up the awards. Yeah. I was like, guys, like in high school, we had the Massachusetts High School Drama Festival,
那么……等等，其实……有个……帝国杂志在2007年左右给我颁过一个奖。然后我去领了这个奖。对。我当时想：伙计们，就像我们在高中时有马萨诸塞州高中戏剧节一样，领了奖。对。我当时想：伙计们，就像在高中时，我们有马萨诸塞州高中戏剧节，
and they would give awards. I was in every one of those plays, killing it, never got an award. I was like, oh, man. Is it true that you have not received an award for acting? Yeah. Are you kidding me? You've been nominated a shit ton of times, I bet, yeah?
他们会颁发奖项。我参演了每一部那样的戏剧，表现惊艳，但从来没得过奖。我当时就想：哦，天哪。你真的没有因为演戏而得过奖吗？对。你在开玩笑吧？我敢打赌你被提名过无数次了吧？
Yeah. Good Lord. Yeah. I mean, I got a God Lord. I got a God Lord. You got a globe? You got a God Lord. Well, that's something. Yeah, that's something. Good Lord. I mean, I got a God Lord. I got a Golden Globe. You got a Golden Globe? Well, that's something. Yeah, that's something. Come on.
对。天哪。对。我是说，我得过一个——天哪。我得过一个——天哪。你得过金球奖？你得过一个——天哪。好吧，那也算。对，那也算。天哪。我是说，我得过一个——天哪。我得过金球奖。你得过金球奖？好吧，那也算。得了吧。
Well, for the Martian, right? For the Martian. Yeah. Because they gave it to me. Oh, for a part. But by the way, thank you. They gave it to me in the category of musical or comedy. No way.
嗯，为了《火星救援》，对吧？为了《火星救援》。对。因为他们把奖颁给了我。哦，为了一个角色。但顺便说一句，谢谢你们。他们把它颁给了我，在音乐或喜剧类别的奖项中。不会吧。
No way. 100%. By the way, it's one of my favorite movies of all time. It was great. I love the guys. it's one of my favorite movies of all time. It really is great. I love the guys. It's so good. Wait, are you still good real hunting now?
绝不可能。100%。顺便说一句，这是我最喜欢的电影之一。太棒了。我太喜欢那些家伙了。这是我最喜欢的电影之一。真的太棒了。我太喜欢那些家伙了。太棒了。等等，你现在《心灵捕手》演得还行吗？
I want to talk to Matt about a couple movies. Can I do this one thing and then I'll hand it off to you? Okay. Tell me your name again. I'm gonna listen. So George Clooney was on a podcast. Okay. And he just was describing this amazing moment when you took Oceans 12 to the Cannes Film
我想跟马特聊几部电影。我能先说这一件事，然后再把话筒交给你吗？好的。再告诉我一次你的名字。我会听着的。所以乔治·克鲁尼之前上了一个播客。好的。他当时正在描述一个非常惊艳的时刻：你把《十二罗汉》带到戛纳电影节的时候
Festival. Do you know the story? Oh, yeah. And so you guys rode on this yacht for the press and Brad Pitt says he wants to climb to the top and take a shirt off and jump off the top. And George was like, oh my god, Brad Pitt takes his shirt off, and it's like something Michelangelo carved. His body was just perfect. And then he says, he looks over at Matt and Matt goes,
节。你知道这个故事吗？哦，对。然后你们坐着这艘游艇去接受采访，布拉德·皮特说他想爬到顶端，脱掉衬衫，然后从顶端跳下去。乔治就说，哦天哪，布拉德·皮特脱了衬衫，就像米开朗琪罗雕刻的一样。他的身材简直完美。然后他说，他看了看马特，马特说，
and you take off your shirt, and it's something like the Pillsbury, Doe Boy car. Right. Right. Wow. Well, you're probably bulking up for a part. I clearly, clearly, I was preparing for something.
然后你脱下衬衫，就像皮尔斯伯里面团小子（Pillsbury Doughboy）的汽车一样。对。对。哇。好吧，你可能是在为某个角色增肌。我显然，显然，我是在为什么做准备。
I literally was like, that was my question. We've all seen Ripley, we've all seen, you know how to get it down. I can, I can get it down if I have to. But I mean, that shot's fired by Clooney. I mean, Listen, Clooney was so scared of getting his picture taken next to Brad with his shirt off,
我当时简直就是——这就是我的问题。我们都看过《天才瑞普利》，我们都看过，你知道怎么把体重减下来。如果非得的话，我能，我能减下来。但我的意思是，克鲁尼开了那一枪。听着，克鲁尼非常害怕自己的照片被拍到和赤膊的布拉德站在一起，
that he didn't even jump off the boat. And later, and he told me later, he's like, I knew you were gonna get hit by it because the paparazzi took pictures. And it's like, you know, it's Brad and the whale. Oh, God, I can't. Stopping off. And we were in the middle of the Mediterranean.
以至于他甚至没有从船上跳下去。后来，他后来告诉我，他说，我当时就知道你会躺枪，因为狗仔队拍了照。这就好比是，你知道的，布拉德和那条鲸鱼。哦，天哪，我受不了。从船上跳下去。而我们当时正处于地中海的正中央。
I just couldn't see if those lenses are so ridiculous. And I didn't even know how they knew we were on that boat. And but George somehow knew. He's got like a spider sense or something, and he's just like, no. I wasn't gonna risk it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But so you do, and you do know how to get it down
我只是没想到那些镜头竟然如此离谱。我甚至不知道他们是怎么知道我们在那艘船上的。但乔治不知怎么就是知道了。他有一种蜘蛛感应之类的东西，然后他就想，不。我才不会去冒那个险。对，对，对。但是呢，你也确实，你也确实知道该怎么减脂
and get in shape because the fucking born movies. Yeah, and that's crazy. Yeah. I think the first time I met you was years ago was at Krasinski's house, and I came in the door, and I don't know if you remember this, I came in the door, and you picked me up. You grabbed me around the way, some picked me up.
并恢复体形，因为拍了那该死的《谍影重重》电影。对，太疯狂了。对。我想我第一次见你还是好几年前在卡拉辛斯基（Krasinski）家，我走进门，我不知道你记不记得，我走进门，你把我抱了起来。你搂着我的腰把我抱了起来。
You'd had a few. But then... At John? At John. At John. Yeah, at John. JK, you guys. I mean, that's John Kruzinski.
你当时喝了点。但后来……在约翰家？在约翰家。在约翰家。对，在约翰家。JK，你们知道的。我的意思是，那是约翰·卡拉辛斯基。
So, bravo. And I think I geeked on you at that time. The born movies to me, I have seen all, well, the four that you've done. I can't even count how many times. Born, ultimatum is the second one? The third one. Third one.
所以，太棒了。而且我想我当时对你顶礼膜拜。对我来说，《谍影重重》电影，我把所有的——好吧，你拍的那四部。我甚至数不清看过多少遍了。《谍影重重》，《谍影重重3》是第二部吗？第三部。第三部。
Born, supremacy is the second one? The third one. Third one. Born supremacy. It was a tragedy to supremacy. To premacy. Yeah. Born supremacy to me is the most... One of the most perfect films. It's got everything. It's got drama.
《谍影重重2》是第二部吗？第三部。第三部。《谍影重重2》。对《谍影重重2》来说是个悲剧。对，至尊。对，谍影重重2对我来说是最……最完美的电影之一。它应有尽有。有剧情。
It's got action. You're so fucking good. And, you know, people say, well, you know, you're doing an action movie. Doing what you do, you have... It's intensity from the moment you start. It's just like super intense, and you're in it,
有动作戏。你太特么棒了。而且，你知道，人们会说，好吧，你知道，你在拍动作片。做你所做的事，你拥有……从你开始的那一刻起，那种强度就拉满了。简直是超级强烈，你全身心投入其中，
and you're just like kicking dudes asses, and strangling them and shit, and... All the while acting, like, I'm not sure how I know how to do this. Yeah, that's... You're a weapon, and you don't even know it. Right. What? Yeah.
你就像是在狂揍那些家伙，勒住他们的脖子之类的，而且……与此同时还要演戏，就像，我不太确定自己怎么知道该怎么做。对，那是……你就是一件武器，而你自己甚至都不知道。对。什么？对。
Exactly. What was that experience like, because that to me is it. And would you ever go through that training process again? Yeah, though, on the last one, I remember I was 45 on the last one and it hurt. Yeah, and people would go like, come by age or come and go, hey man, how did you get and I go not worth it? Right, yeah.
完全正确。那种经历是怎样的，因为对我来说，那就是核心所在。而且你还会再次经历那种训练过程吗？对，不过，拍最后一部的时候，我记得拍最后一部时我45岁了，而且真的很痛苦。对，人们会说，比如根据年龄或者走过来，嘿，伙计，你是怎么练的，我说不值得！对，没错。
What about Liam Neeson is doing? Every single film he's doing is more intense than the next and he's not forty five no no he's he's great i mean i don't know i mean some some people but but it's a great when you're younger even when you're in your thirties you're doing supremacy and you're doing all this crazy shit and supremacy was directed by uh... greengrass all greengrass is an incredible director that's why they all work it's always the director what was what was that yeah and but but you but you're giving him a lot of credit, but you deserve so much.
连姆·尼森在做的事呢？他拍的每一部电影都比上一部更紧张刺激，而且他可不止45岁不，不，他很——他很棒，我的意思是，我不知道，我的意思是，有些人，但当你年轻时真的很棒，甚至当你三十多岁的时候，你在拍《谍影重重2》，你在搞这些疯狂的破事，而且《谍影重重2》是由——呃，格林格拉斯（Greengrass）导演的。哦，格林格拉斯是一位不可思议的导演，这就是为什么他们都合作，永远都是导演的问题。那是——那是怎样——是的，但是——但是你给了他很多功劳，但你也配得上那么多。
What was that process like for you? Will you beat up every day? No, I mean, they make it. Look, the Tom Cruises of the World who do their stunts literally hang off a plane and do that. Yeah, I remember I had dinner with him once and it was after he did the one where he ran around the building. Oh yeah, not without him.
那对你来说是一个怎样的过程？你每天都被打得很惨吗？不，我的意思是，他们做到了。你看，世上的汤姆·克鲁斯亲自做特技，真的挂在飞机外面做那种事。对，我记得我和他吃过一次饭，那是在他拍了那个绕着大楼奔跑的电影之后。哦，对，就是《碟中谍》。
Yeah, not without him. And Dubai. Yeah, yeah. I mean, he's 1,500 feet up on a cable running around the building. Yeah, that's crazy. And I go, can you tell me how that happened? And he goes, yeah. He's a really intense guy.
对，就是《碟中谍》。还有在迪拜。对，对，对。我的意思是，他挂在1500英尺高空的缆绳上绕着大楼奔跑。对，太疯狂了。然后我问，你能告诉我那是怎么发生的吗？他说，可以。他是个非常情绪高涨的家伙。
And he's like, yeah, I'll tell you how it happened. He's like, so far. I go, all right, all right. And I'm in. I'm like, OK. And he goes, so I go to the seat, he goes, I didn't think about this shot for 15 years. And I go, wow, really? And he goes, yeah, I knew it, and he goes,
他就说，行吧，我告诉你怎么发生的。他说，这么说吧。我说，好吧，好吧。然后我进入状态。我想，好吧。然后他说，所以我去找安全员，他说，这就是我要做的。我把一切都摆在桌面上，安全员说，我们不能这么做。太危险了，你不能这么做。所以我换了个新安全员。这只是开始，你不能这么做。所以我换了个新安全员。这只是个开始，他故事的开始。我直接说停。这就是我们不同的地方。
and I go to the safety guy, I go, here's what I'm gonna do. And I lay it all out, safety guy goes, we can't do that. It's too dangerous, you can't do that. So I get a new safety guy. That's the beginning, you can't do that. So I get a new safety guy. That's the beginning, the beginning of his story. And I just go stop. That's where we're different.
当安全员说，不，我就想，哦，安全员说。这不是个好主意。你因为所有这些经历而留下什么长期伤痛吗？不，不，不。你是认真的吗？不，不，不。我的意思是，那些打斗戏会留下一些小擦伤和割伤之类的，但没什么大碍，
When the safety guy says, no, I'm like, oh, safety guy says. It's not a good idea. Do you have any long lasting injuries from all of that? No, no, no. Are you serious? No, no, no. I mean, little nicks and cuts and stuff from those fight scenes, but nothing,
他们拍的时候都收着拳呢。事实上，在第一部电影《谍影重重》中，我在一间公寓里跟这家伙打架。尼基·诺德（Nikki Naude）是他的名字，尼基是个……在巴黎。在巴黎。对，不，我知道。笑声
they're pulling their punches. In fact, on the first movie, the born identity, I fight this guy in an apartment. Nikki node was his name, and Nikki was a... In Paris. In Paris. Yeah, no, I know. LAUGHTER
你为什么要在告诉我一些我本来就知道的事，马特？抱歉，抱歉。尼基是个职业选手，曾是一名职业踢拳手，他既是演员又是特技替工。所以在我们拍摄前我找到他，我说，听着，我真的很抱歉。我，我，你知道，我一直在练拳击并做各种准备来进入状态，但我说，我可能会不小心
Why are you telling me stuff I know, Matt? Sorry, sorry. Nikki was a professional, had been a professional kickboxer and he was an actor and a stuntman. And so I went to him before we shot and I said, look, I'm really sorry. I'm, I'm, you know, I've been boxing and doing all the stuff to get ready, but I go, I'm gonna accidentally
打到你。我的意思是，我就是知道我会的，我提前感到非常抱歉。而且我打你一次，就送你一瓶香槟。尼基听了说，这挺好，行。所以到了一天结束的时候，我欠了那家伙一箱香槟。但他习惯了职业搏击。
hit you. I mean, I just know I am and I'm really sorry in advance. And for every time I hit you, I'll give you a bottle of champagne. And Nikki goes, this is good, yes. So by the end of the day, I owed the dude a case of champagne. But he had been used to fighting professionally.
他当时就觉得，一点都不疼。他当时就觉得，他甚至觉得有点不好意思。他当时就觉得，你打得一点都不疼。对。他甚至觉得有点不好意思。他顺着剧情演了下去。他当时就觉得，太棒了。他当时就觉得，无论什么时候你想拍打斗戏，我的意思是——我想了解另一部我非常喜欢的、你参演的电影，那就是《无间道风云》。
He was like, he did not hurt at all. He was like, he was so embarrassed. He was like, you did not hurt at all. Right. He was like, he was so embarrassed. He was leaning into it. He was like, great. He was like, any time you want to do a fight scene, I mean, I want to know another favorite movie that I love, that you're in, is The Departed.
我也很喜欢，是的。真疯狂，你在你这个年纪演了这么多电影，而且没有一部是烂片。
And which I love, yes. It's crazy how many movies you've been in at your age and none of them suck. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, and the quality that you've maintained is just stunning. You really deserve to really have Friday. I appreciate it. Thank you. It's true. It's true. I want to ask about the departed, because I did a movie
而且你保持的质量简直惊人。你真的绝对值得拥有星期五。我很感激。谢谢。这是真的。这是真的。我想问问关于《无间道风云》的事，因为我也和杰克·尼克尔森（Jack Nicholson）合作过一部电影，叫《遗愿清单》。当然。第一天——虽然没那么棒。但在《遗愿清单》的第一天，我们坐在一辆宾利还是什么的里面。
with Jack Nicholson as well called The Bucket List. Sure. And the first, not as much a plus. But the first day of The Bucket List we were in this like Bentley or something. And they took the windshield out to put the camera in. And I didn't know, I was the first day, and Morgan Freeman and Jack Nicholson are sitting in the back, and I'm sitting in the passenger seat in the front. And in your mind, you know, you're like, should I break the ice with a joke?
他们把挡风玻璃拆了以便把摄像机放进去。我当时不知道，那是我第一天，摩根·弗里曼和杰克·尼克尔森坐在后排，我坐在前排的副驾驶座上。在你心里，你知道的，你就在想，我应该用一个笑话来打破僵局吗？
Should I not? I don't know these guys yet. I'm not, you know, it's only the first day of shooting. So idiot goes, all right, I'm going to go for it. Maybe someday when you make it big, you can sit in the front. Oh. Oh. Silence.
我该不该这么做？我还不太了解这些人。我不是，你知道的，这只是拍摄的第一天。所以这个白痴就想，好吧，我要豁出去了。也许有一天等你大红大紫了，你就能坐在前排了。哦。哦。一片寂静。
Silence. Oh. Nothing. Cricket. Nothing, cricket. They're literally looking at their lines, and they just go. Silence. Nothing. Crickets. Nothing. Crickets. They literally look in other lines, and they just go, no. Oh, shit.
一片寂静。哦。毫无反应。只有蟋蟀叫。毫无反应，只有蟋蟀叫。他们真的在看着台词，然后他们就说。一片寂静。毫无反应。只有蟋蟀叫。毫无反应。只有蟋蟀叫。他们真的在看台词，然后他们就说，不。哦，该死。
And then the last one was, we would now were like a month or two in the thing, and I'm like, well, now they're my pals, right? And so I'm sitting in, you know, a little video village. Tracey video village is a thing where you can watch playback and it's like off of the set. How fun is it that he can look at Tracey well he does it? So I'm sitting there and I thought, oh gosh, now it would be the perfect time to play
然后最后一次是，我们当时已经拍了一个月或两个月了，我想，好吧，现在他们是我的好朋友了，对吧？所以我坐在，你知道的，一个小的视频监视器前。特雷西，视频监视器就是那种你可以观看回放的地方，而且它离片场有点远。他能边拍边看特雷西的画面，这该有多有趣啊？所以我坐在那里心想，哦天哪，现在绝对是玩个游戏的绝佳时机，
a game, right? Because we're waiting while they're lighting the scene, it's going to take like a half hour or whatever. So I say to Morgan and Jack and Rob Reiner, who's directing it, and some crew guys who are sitting around, I go, hey guys, I got a great idea. Let's play a game.
对吧？因为我们在等他们打光，大概要花上半小时左右什么的。所以我对摩根、杰克和正在执导该片的罗伯·莱纳（Rob Reiner），以及周围坐着的一些剧组人员说，嘿伙计们，我有个好主意。我们来玩个游戏吧。
Let's go around the room and name the movie, your embarrassed to say you've never seen. Embarrass to say you've never seen. I go, I'll go first. I've never seen the Godfather. That was the end of the game. That was the end of the game. Because next half hour, everyone's like, hey, she's just guys never seen the Godfather. That was the end of the game. That was the end of the game. Because next half hour everyone's like,
我们在房间里轮流说出一部你不好意思说自己从没看过的电影。不好意思说自己从没看过的电影。我说，我先来。我从来没看过《教父》。那就是游戏的终结。那就是游戏的终结。因为接下来的半小时里，每个人都在说，嘿，这傻大个居然没看过《教父》。那就是游戏的终结。那就是游戏的终结。因为接下来的半小时里每个人都在说，
hey, this guy's never, you've never seen the fuck of what? And I'm like, is somebody else gonna go? Like nobody else. So, I know where you're going with this. The parted, but the parted is, is certainly one of those movies that you don't really, you're not allowed to say you're a fan of movies if you've not seen that movie. You're not really. You're're a fan of movies if you've not seen that movie.
嘿，这家伙从来没——你从来没看过《教父》？我在想，还会有人接话吗？结果根本没人接。所以，我知道你接下来要说到哪了。《无间道风云》，但《无间道风云》绝对是那种电影，如果你没看过那部电影，你真的没资格说自己是个影迷。你真的不算。你是个影迷，如果你没看过那部电影。
You're not really. You're not such a great movie. That's a good movie. God. Yeah. What was that experience like? How did you come about that part? I was, we were making oceans to help.
你真的不算。你不是那样的一部好电影。那是一部好电影。天哪。对。那段经历是怎样的？你是怎么得到那个角色的？我当时正在——我们当时在拍《十二罗汉》。
Yeah, that's the truth. And Brad Pitt, you know, is a pretty prolific producer. And I don't know if you could guys know, but he produced that movie. And he just came up to it's the weirdest thing, because every actor's dream is to work with Marty Scorsese, right? And we were sitting there. Do you see that's a guy directed the movie?
对，千真万确。布拉德·皮特，你知道的，是个相当多产的制片人。我不知道你们知不知道，但他制作了那部电影。他径直走过来——这太奇怪了，因为每个演员的梦想都是和马丁·斯科塞斯合作，对吧？我们当时正坐着。你看，那是执导过那部电影的家伙——
Among others. And we were literally, this is the worst, this is like how many names am I going to drop that I have to pick? You're allowed here. We were at George Clooney's house in Italy. We figured you knew him. And Lucian and I was before we were married. So this is 2004, I think, because we got married in 2005, and we were sitting there at the pool.
其中之一。我们当时真的——这太糟了，这就像我要抛出多少个我不得不提及的名字啊？在这里你是被允许的。我们在乔治·克鲁尼位于意大利的家里。我们猜你认识他。还有露西亚（Lucian），那是在我们结婚之前。所以我想这是2004年，因为我们在2005年结婚的，我们当时正坐在泳池边。
And Brad Pitt walked over. Sounds like a very nice weekend now. Look, we were working, okay. It was hard. It was really hard. And Brad kind of put his towel down and sat down on the chair. And next to us, and goes, hey, Maddie, you want to do a movie with Martin Scorsese?
布拉德·皮特走了过来。听起来现在是个非常美好的周末了。听着，我们在工作，好吗？很不容易。真的很不容易。布拉德放下毛巾，坐在了椅子上。就在我们旁边，然后说，嘿，马蒂，你想和马丁·斯科塞斯合作拍部电影吗？
No way. I swear to God, that's what he said. And I was like, yeah. And he was like, no, I'm actually serious. Wow. I'm like, what are you actually talking about? Drop the script on your towel, right then. Yeah.
绝不可能。我向上帝发誓，他就是这么说的。我当时就说，好啊。然后他说，不，我其实是认真的。哇。我说，你到底在说什么？把剧本直接扔在你的毛巾上，就在那时。对。
And he goes, and then the script went, Woo! Yeah. All right, all right. All right. Yeah. Page one. Yeah.
然后他说，接着剧本就——呜！对。好吧，好吧。好吧。对。第一页。对。
Yeah. Did you, did you at any point say, well, hang on a second, Brad, why are you playing this part? He felt like he had aged out of it. Really? Because the guy goes through the police academy and he just, he's just unbelievably generous and he goes, no, I think it'd be better if you did it.
对。你有没有，有没有在哪个瞬间说，等等一下，布拉德，为什么你要演这个角色？他觉得自己年龄过了演这个角色的阶段。真的吗？因为那个角色要通过警察学校的训练，而他就是——他简直慷慨得令人难以置信，他说，不，我觉得你来演会更好。
Because Leo's gonna play this one role. How old is Brad Pitt? Brad is, I don't know. I'm 51 and I think. I think he's like 56 or something. 50, 70, 80. Yeah, something like that. He looks incredible, first of all. I love him. Guys it's like 58. Yeah, something like that. He looks incredible, first of all.
因为莱昂纳多要演另一个角色。布拉德·皮特多大年纪？布拉德他，我不知道。我51岁了，我想。我想他大概56岁左右吧。50，70，80。对，差不多吧。首先他看起来帅呆了。我爱死他了。伙计们，他已经58岁了。对，差不多吧。首先他看起来帅呆了。
I love it. Guys, he looks awful. Yeah, I look terrible. I love me some Brad Pitt. I saw, I know, I really do. So do I. So nice guy. Oh, he's such a nice guy.
我爱死他了。伙计们，他看起来糟透了。对，我看起来真糟糕。我可太喜欢布拉德·皮特了。我看到——我知道，我真的很喜欢。我也是。真是个好人。哦，他真的是个好人。
And he's so handsome. And I know. And it's hard to not look at him. It's so hard not to look at him. So we were, like, right before the pandemic, we were in Los Angeles, we're at Bunny Verre concert. And I like Wisconsin, so I know those guys. Justin Vernon and Sean Carrey and all those guys.
而且他长得太帅了。我知道。而且很难不把目光从他身上移开。太难不去看他了。所以我们在——就像在疫情爆发前不久，我们在洛杉矶，在博尼·维尔（Bon Iver）的音乐会上。我很喜欢威斯康星州，所以我认识那些家伙。贾斯汀·弗农（Justin Vernon）、肖恩·凯里（Sean Carey）以及所有那些人。
And so anyway, we were hanging out before the show and just chatting and Brad came in to sit down. And he said, sound like, go, we're talking for a second. I said, you know, Brad, I was thinking, you know what, movie has aged really well. And he said, what, I said, Benjamin Button. That's a great laugh. It's a great joke, right?
所以无论如何，我们在演出前闲逛，随便聊聊天，布拉德走过来坐下。他说，听起来像，去吧，我们聊了一会儿。我说，你知道，布拉德，我在想，你知道的，有部电影时间越久越有味道。他说，什么，我说，本杰明·巴顿奇事。这笑得太棒了。这是一个绝妙的笑话，对吧？
It's a great laugh. He's a great joke, right? It's a great laugh. He's a great joke. And he paused for a second, and then he started laughing. And I was like, I'm not ripping on the movie. I mean, it's a perfectly destructive joke. And he was great about it. Yeah, movie is so fun.
这笑得太棒了。他开的玩笑真棒，对吧？这笑得太棒了。他开的玩笑真棒。他停顿了一会儿，然后开始大笑。我当时就想，我可不是在贬低这部电影。我的意思是，这是一个非常具有毁灭性的笑话。他对此表现得很大度。对，那部电影太有趣了。
Yeah, he's somebody who, because we started working together 20 years ago on Oceans. And it was just mystifying like how, because he's been the most famous guy, and even Jerry Wine Trabber producers at it. I was with Elvis, every generation has one guy, Brad's the guy. And it's true just the effect that he has on people,
对，他是那种人，因为我们20年前在《十一罗汉》上开始合作。这简直让人匪夷所思，因为他是最出名的家伙，甚至连制片人杰里·韦恩特劳布（Jerry Weintraub）也这么说。我和埃尔维斯在一起过，每个世代都有一个代表人物，布拉德就是那个人。确实如此，仅仅是他对人们产生的影响，
but I've never seen an effect like that, but with so, like, he doesn't do anything to court it, he doesn't do anything to, he's the most regular guy's from Missouri, he just couldn't be, he couldn't be more normal, Jason. Yeah, he's really normal. Really normal.
但我从未见过这样巨大的影响，而且他是如此地——他从来不刻意讨好，他什么都不做去博取关注，他是来自密苏里州的最普通的人，他简直不能再——不能再更普通了，杰森。对，他真的很普通。非常普通。
He fights, he pushes down the instinct to be shitty to people. He actually said that. He got, he elicited for me at that same thing after the show. He said, hey man, I just want to say, we've done this little show in Netflix called Flake, and he goes, hey man, I need a little, it's a little, but he goes, he goes,
他在跟自己做斗争，他在压抑那种对人刻薄的本能。他真的这么说了。就在演出结束后那件事上，他对我流露了真情。他说，嘿，伙计，我只想说，我们在网飞（Netflix）上做了这个小节目叫《宿敌》（Flake），然后他说，嘿，伙计，我需要一点，虽然很小，但他接着说，
man, I just want to say, I just, I loved your show so much, man, I watched the whole thing. I was so shocked and I was like, really? He goes, oh, I just loved it and he gave me a big hug. And I said, thanks man, and then we go to the door to go out. I said, well, I'll see you guys later and I was like, really? Because, oh, I just loved it and he gave me a big hug and I said, thanks, man. And then we go to the door to go out. I said, well, I'll see you guys later. I walk outside and I slid down the wall. I went, oh, my God.
伙计，我只想说，我太喜欢你的节目了，伙计，我把整部剧都看完了。我当时震惊极了，然后我说，真的吗？他说，哦，我太喜欢了，还给了我一个大大的拥抱。我说，谢谢你，伙计，然后我们走到门口准备出去。我说，好吧，回头见，我当时心想，真的吗？因为，哦，我太喜欢了，他给了我一个大大的拥抱，我说，谢谢，伙计。然后我们走到门口准备出去。我说，好吧，回头见，各位。我走到外面，顺着墙滑了下去，心想，哦，天哪。
Oh, my God. Yeah, yeah. Who do you think he thought of? He brought up my girlfriend and she's like, this is great. Who do you think he thought you were? Are you mistaken for her? Yeah. He was passing it out. you were. Are you mistaken for...
哦，天哪。对，对。你觉得他当时以为他是谁？他提到了我的女朋友，而她觉得这太棒了。你觉得他以为你是谁？你被误认为——
I want to introduce everybody to the real Jason. He finally showed up. Well speaking of normal Matthew Damon you're one of the most normal people I've ever known and thank you for being here. That's it. Oh my God. That's you. That was fast. I know. Thank you.
我想向大家介绍真正的杰森。他终于现身了。说到普通，马修·达蒙，你是我认识的最普通的人之一，谢谢你能来到这里。就这样。哦，天哪。那就是你。真快。我知道。谢谢。
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. You're putting here. Thanks, guys. Wow. Wow. You guys.
谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。你在这儿。谢谢你们，伙计们。哇。哇。你们。
That's great. That's great. You guys. You guys. That's great. You guys. That's great. You guys. That's great. You guys Amazing you guys came for us and that's what's important
太棒了。太棒了。你们。你们。太棒了。你们。太棒了。你们。太棒了。你们。太棒了，你们能来支持我们，这才是最重要的。
You guys came for us and Matt was so nice to be here. Thank you guys so much for coming We but no you know I was gonna say I we said everything I've said everything there I would repeat it a thousand times. I love that man Yeah, like all talking about kindness and everything and I've said everything there, I would repeat it a thousand times. I love that man. He's the kind, like, all talking about kindness and everything. And it is kind of a, by the way, I could have asked him a thousand questions about the Martian because I love the Martian. But I just love him and he's so talented.
你们能来支持我们，马特能来这里真是太好了。非常感谢你们的到来。我们——但是不，你知道我本来想说，我——我们说的一切，我刚才说的一切，我都愿意重复一千遍。我爱那个男人。是的，就像谈到善良以及所有这些一样，我刚才说的一切，我都愿意重复一千遍。我爱那个男人。他那么善良，就像，所有关于善良的讨论等等。而且这确实算是一个——顺便说一句，我本来可以问他一千个关于《火星救援》的问题，因为我太喜欢《火星救援》了。但我就是喜欢他，而且他太有才华了。
He's so talented and so normal and so kind and generous and always just warm the people and yeah I do think it's interesting though you know when he did the talent of mr. Ripley which is about I get what's that for me here it comes no no this we're not doing a buy no no not yet he did when he's usually usually this is where Sean starts wrapping up in his brain breaks trying to work his way to a buy and And you can feel it. No, I'm just telling it right now. Talented Mr. Ripley.
他如此有才华，又如此普通、善良、慷慨，总是对人那么热情，是的，我确实觉得很有趣，你知道的，当他出演《天才瑞普利》时，那是一部关于——我懂，那是为了什么——来了，来了，不，不，我们可不是在搞买卖——不，不，还没呢。他演的时候，通常——通常这个时候肖恩开始在脑子里进行总结，他的大脑在飞速运转，试图转到广告时间，并且你能感觉得到。不，我只是现在就说出来。《天才瑞普利》。
I was gonna say, in the town that Mr. Ripley plays a gay con man, and that's about the time you start hanging out with me. But I was sitting here, I was trying to think of a biocene but he's so nice, he like, you put your hand in the cage that he's in, he'd never take a bite out of it. And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,ey. What about it? What about it? Listen, if you want to pick on anybody after the show, these three said they want us to get rid of it. What I'm pitching, but what about if we just change it to, I'm pitching these guys,
我本来想说，在《天才瑞普利》里他扮演一个同性恋诈骗犯，而差不多也就是从那时候起你开始跟我混在一起。但我刚刚坐在这里，我正绞尽脑汁想找个广告切入点，但他太好了，就好像，你把手伸进他所在的笼子里，他绝对不会咬你一口。而我却在想，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，浦西。怎么着？怎么着？听着，如果你想在节目结束后找谁的麻烦，这三个人说他们想让我们摆脱这个。我提出的建议是，如果我们把它改成，我向这几位提议，
and we change it to a C, right? And then we can find a C into, but we can't get it anymore by. Wait, wait, wait. He keeps pitching the C. Well, like it's a tell, you know. I know, but let's vote on it right now. So, bye.
然后我们把它改成C，对吧？然后我们可以把C融入到，但我们再也不能用“拜拜”了。等一下，等一下。他一直在推销那个C。好吧，这就像是一个暗示，你知道的。我知道，但我们现在就投票决定吧。所以，拜拜。
CHEERING AND APPLAUSE And... Or... Or see ya. CHEERING AND APPLAUSE I didn't pitch it very well. What's your one-know-which-one? Bye!
欢呼与掌声 然后……或者……或者再见。欢呼与掌声 我没推销好。你究竟喜欢哪一个？拜拜！
Bye! Thank you, guys know it's one one. Bye! Thank you, guys. Thank you, guys. Thank you. Thank you. Smart. Smart. Smart.
拜拜！谢谢大家，都知道是哪一个。拜拜！谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢。谢谢。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Umbjurf. SmartLess. Hey listeners, you need to know that Wondery's shocking true crime podcast over my dead body is back for a fourth season, Gone Hunting. This newest season covers the story of Mike Williams. It was Mike's sixth wedding anniversary when he set off on a hunting trip into the gator
SmartLess由贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbakow）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·昂伯乔夫（Rob Umbjurf）100%有机手工打造。SmartLess。嘿，听众们，你们需要知道的是，Wondery惊悚真实罪案播客《我死以后》（Over My Dead Body）第四季“去打猎”（Gone Hunting）强势回归。最新一季讲述了迈克·威廉姆斯（Mike Williams）的故事。那是迈克结婚六周年纪念日，当时他出发前往佛罗里达州北部短吻鳄
infested swamps of North Florida. He figured he'd be back in time to take his wife Denise out to celebrate, but he never came back. Friends and loved ones feared he met his fate through bad luck and a group of hungry alligators leaving his young family behind. Except that's not what happened at all. And after 17 years, a kidnapping and the uncovering of a secret love triangle, the truth would finally be revealed. Enjoy over my dead body, gone hunting on the Wonder App or wherever you get your podcasts. You can finally be revealed. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
横行的沼泽地进行一次狩猎之旅。他盘算着能在带妻子丹尼斯（Denise）出去庆祝之前赶回来，但他再也没有回来。朋友和亲人们担心他因为厄运和一群饥饿的短吻鳄而遭遇不测，留下了年轻的家人。然而事实并非如此。在经历了17年、一场绑架以及一个秘密三角恋情被揭露之后，真相终于大白于天下。欢迎在Wondery App或您获取播客的任何地方收听《我死以后：去打猎》。真相终于大白。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。